Ich bin ein Kumpel von Kumpel. Ich bin ein Kumpel von Kumpel.
War bei meinem Vater auch. Der hatte einen Ford Focus. Und da bist du gefahren und irgendwann sind sämtliche Anzeigen angegangen. Für eine Zehntelsekunde sofort wieder aus. Das Licht ist ausgegangen und sofort wieder an. Und das ist also wirklich in so einem Sekundenbruchteil alles passiert. Dass du im Auto gesessen hast und gedacht hast, war da gerade was? Das war richtig hart. Wenn dir das mal auf einer abschüssigen Straße passiert und du gerade bremsen musst.
Ja, ABS und Konsorten. Ich frag mich dann nur, was bei dir bei Wire kommt. Also wenn die Steuerung dann auch noch über Draht etc.
erfolgt.
Wie das zum Beispiel beim neuen Airbus und so weiter der Fall ist. Ich meine, da hab ich ein bisschen mehr Vertrauen. Aber es ist halt auch so eine Sache, wo man vielleicht mal nachdenkt.
Wollen die das wirklich in ihre Autos einbauen irgendwann?
Das kommt jetzt im Flugzeug, das wird sicherlich auch an den Autos kommen.
Du brauchst ein System und das kannst du eben mit den Motorspeuerungen.
Mit den Waschmaschinen, da finde ich eben auch wieder schön, wie man das verfolgen kann. Also wenn man so ein bisschen unterschiedliche Waschmaschinenmodelle über die letzten Jahrzehnte oder Jahre sich eben anschaut. Das waren halt am Anfang so elektromechanische Wahlschalter mit unglaublich vielen Kabeln dahinter. Und ein Motor, der diesen Schalter gedreht hat und diese ganze Mechanik. Und da ist dann tatsächlich einfach der Kostengrundfaktor, warum man jetzt eben auf integrierte Elektronik und auf Embedded-Systeme geht. Man kann diese ganzen Kabel sparen. Die ganze komplexe Mechanik braucht man nicht. Man braucht nur noch irgendwie ein paar Up-Down-Taster oder vielleicht ein Touchscreen oder irgend sowas. Alles viel billiger als diese komplexe Mechanik, die dahinter steckt. Ja, das ist ja nicht im Interesse des Herstellers. Der will ja nur seine Produktionskosten verlängern, aber doch nicht den Kunden.
Ach, Entschuldigung, ich war grad naiv.
Ich glaub, dass ich aber jetzt...
Es ist ja eher noch im Interesse des Herstellers, wenn er den Service an sich bindet, ne? Wenn er das versorgt, dass ein Reparaturauftrag auch garantiert bei ihm landet.
Stimmt allerdings. Jan, danke für deinen Anruf. Chaosradio 105 von dem Embedded Systems ist unser Thema heute Abend. Wir haben auch einen Anrufer, das liest sich sehr seltsam, was ich hier auf dem Bildschirm stehen habe. Thomas aus Würzburg, du baust was?
Erstmal einen schönen guten Abend an das ganze Chaosradio-Thema und an den Harald.
Ja, Mahlzeit.
Ja, ich wollte ein etwas eigentümliches Embedded System vermelden und zwar geht es dabei um Deutschlands ersten Pico-Satelliten.
Pico-Satellit heißt Satellit in Umlaufbahn schießen, sehr sehr klein, richtig? Soll auch geschossen werden in Umlaufbahn?
Wird er am 27. September.
Nee, wie?
September.
Aber auf welche Weise?
28 Tagen.
Hast du da mal eine UAL bitte?
Das ist, wenn du CubeSat Uni Würzburg einfach mal googeln.
Auf welche Weise schießt du den hoch?
Die Russen machen das, der wird in einer russischen Rakete, das hat sich jetzt auch mehrfach verzögert, weil die letzte Rakete von dem selben Typ hat dieses Serious-Projekt von den Russen in Sand gesetzt und daraufhin wird jetzt die Rakete nochmal überholt, mit der unser Satellit hochkommt. Und da wird der Satellit hochgeschossen und auf diesem Satellit befindet sich ein Microlinux. Da ist ein H8-Prozessor drauf mit Microlinux, der macht das gesamte Housekeeping und das ganze Giraffel und was halt so auf den Satelliten so anfällt.
Uwe 1?
Ja genau, Uwe 1.
University of Würzburgs Experimental Satellite One. So heißt dieses Gerät, sieht ganz putzig aus. www.sieben.informatik.uni-würzburg.de slash cubesat Und was macht dieser Satellit dann?
Der Satellit ist erstmal, primär ist der Satellit erstmal in der Umlaufbahn. Also es gibt auf diesen Satelliten momentan keine wirklich sinnvolle Nutzlast. Es sind ein paar Thermometer oben. Es ist ein bisschen Spannungsversorgung. Es ist die Funktechnik da. Es wird eben ein Linux oben sein, was eine IP-Verbindung baut. Sinn des Satelliten ist, auch nachdem das ein Lehrstuhl für Informatik ist, ist auch den Satelliten zu bauen. Der ist übrigens auch da komplett gebaut worden. Mit dem Satelliten soll hauptsächlich Kommunikation über IP getestet werden. Das heißt, es geht darum, dass der Satellit z.B. von verschiedenen Bodenstationen empfangen wird und dann in Roaming gemacht werden kann. So dass z.B. das endgültige Ziel der ganzen Aktion sieht so aus, dass letztendlich der Forscher, der seine Nutzlast in einem solchen Satelliten hat, wenn das Ganze höher integriert ist und eben dann noch Platz für einen Nutzlast ist irgendwann mal, dann kann der Forscher einfach von seinem Schreibtisch aus seinen Satelliten pingen. Braucht sich keine Gedanken drüber zu machen, wo der gerade ist. Wenn der einfach von irgendeiner Bodenstation in Höher- oder Sende-Empfangsreichweise ist, dann kann er den erreichen. Das ist jetzt also dieses spezielle Projekt, um das es da geht.
Was habt ihr da für Technik im Einsatz?
Das ist ein Funkgerät, ein PR430. Wenn das was sagt, denn Amateurfunkern tut das wahrscheinlich, das ist modifiziert. Vielen Dank dafür auch an Stefan Reimann, der das gemacht hat, falls er das hören sollte oder mitkriegen sollte. Das sendet und empfängt auf 70 Zentimetern. 437,505 MHz ist die Frequenz für Amateurfunker. Darin eingebaut ist auch ein Soft-Modem, das heißt, das ist eigentlich schon wieder ein Embedded System. Da ist also ein Embedded System im Embedded System. Und ansonsten ist ein CPU-Board, da ist ein H8-Prozessor, 16 MB RAM, ein bisschen Flash, was man so braucht.
Was man so braucht, wenn man Pico-Satelliten...
Ja, wenn man da einen Linux drauf haben möchte, wenn man IP-Stack-Parameter testen möchte, wenn man vielleicht auch mal ein Programm hochladen möchte und so weiter.
Und kann man den auch noch irgendwie updaten, nachdem er in Orbit geschossen wurde?
Theoretisch geht das, wir können den oben flashen. Allerdings werden wir das erst bei mich machen.
Habt ihr denn so einen winzigen Antrieb gebaut?
Nein, nein, nein, der Satellit ist antriebslos. Der Satellit kann sich lediglich mit Hilfe von Magneten im Erdmagnetfeld ausrichten. Das ist auch sehr geschickt, weil dann ist nämlich die Antenne auch überhaupt irgendwie ausgerichtet.
Respekt.
Und wie gesagt, das da oben zu flashen ist vielleicht nicht so geschickt die Idee, weil irgendwann müssten wir dann einen Space Shuttle hochschicken. So, hier habt ihr dann einen JTAG Adapter. Also vielleicht machen wir das. Also wir haben natürlich auch schon Bugs in unserer Software gefunden. Der Satellit ist seit Weihnachten in Russland. Und wir haben jede Menge Software-Feed, also nicht jede Menge, aber wir haben den einen oder anderen Software-Bug gefunden und haben jetzt quasi keine Chancen mehr, die Software abzudaten. Und für einiges gibt es natürlich Walkarounds. Also die Missionslaufzeit ist ein halbes Jahr oder so, aber wenn der Satellit länger leben sollte, werden wir das vermutlich mal versuchen, ja. Ja, ich denke mal, das ist vielleicht am KNF-Kongress oder so, dass wir da vielleicht auch noch das eine oder andere Wort zu dem Thema sagen werden.
KNF-Kongress?
Da weiß jetzt nur der Harald was mit anzufangen. Aber er kann ja nochmal Werbung dafür machen.
Für die wenigen Zuhörer aus Franken, die hier anwesend sind, gibt es einen Kommunikationsnetz Franken-Kongress, der ist immer im November jeden Jahres.
Ich könnte auch überlegen, einen Vortrag einzureichen für den 22. Chaos Communication-Kongress, den ich an dieser Stelle nochmal bewerben möchte. Ende des Jahres www.ccc.de slash-Kongress slash 2005. Da ist auch gerade der Call for Papers draußen. Bis zum 1.10. darf auch noch fleißig eingereicht werden. Alles was lustig und interessant ist, hat ja eine Chance angenommen zu werden.
Thomas, hin! Was, nochmal?
Wenn ich da Zeit finde und so, was ich gerade noch sagen wollte, abschließend vielleicht zu dem Thema Embedded Systems. Was für einen Sinn hat das Ding da drin, mag man sich vielleicht fragen. Der Sinn ist ganz einfach der, dass der Einsatz von einem Betriebssystem, von eben Linux, von dieser ganzen Embedded System Technik, die Entwicklungszeit und auch die Komplexität der Entwicklung zu einem normalen 0815-Satelliten, wie er jetzt in klassischer Technik, diskreter Elektronik vielleicht aufgebaut würde, massiv verkürzt und massiv vereinfacht. Natürlich unter dem Zugeständnis an vielleicht eine Zuverlässigkeit. Vermutlich ist dieses Embedded System, was wir nicht haben, oder was wir haben, nicht so zuverlässig wie ein diskret aufgebauter Satellit. Aber ein diskret aufgebauter Satellit würde niemals in 10 x 10 x 10 cm passen. Man kann da eben dann mit Hilfe der Embedded Systems Technik eine gewisse Zugeständnisse machen, gewisse Kompromisse eingehen.
Was kostet euer Gerät so?
Der Satellit, das weiß ich nicht, das ist ein Einzelstück.
Nur von den Bauteilen her meine ich jetzt so, vom Materialwert.
Von den Bauteilen her, also das CPU-Bord und die Stromversorgung kann man wahrscheinlich für unter 100 Euro nachbauen.
Aber das ist nicht der ganze Satellit.
Nee, der Satellit ist dann noch... Ich sage ja die Stromversorgung. Es kommen zum Beispiel noch Solarzellen dazu. Die haben eigentlich gar keinen Preis, weil das sind irgendwelche Test-Solarzellen mit extrem hoher Effektivität, weil man ja sehr wenig Fläche hat auf so einem kleinen Satelliten. Also irgendwie drei- oder Vier-Schicht-Solarzellen, die mit Spezialschäber aufgetragen sind, was weiß ich noch, was alles. Also ein Preisschild kann ich an den Satelliten so jetzt nicht dranhängen.
Aber so ein niedriger Stromverbrauch ist sozusagen bei euch auf jeden Fall ein Thema.
Ja, das ist ganz wichtig. Wir haben auch die CPU und die ganzen Geschichten danach rausgewählt. Also ich hatte irgendwie mal eine Liste mit 150 CPUs, die in Frage kommen. Und dann haben wir erstmal alles, was über 20 mA gebraucht hat, rausgestrichen. Und dann haben wir weiter geguckt.
Und was ist das jetzt? Da muss ich nochmal fragen. Hier steht H8S-CPU.
Und da haben wir uns eben aus der Serie eine CPU rausgesucht. Die Bedingung war, dass wir einen Linux oder einen Microlinux jetzt in dem Fall drauf laufen haben können. Und dass es eben den Satelitenanforderungen gerecht wird. Also was wir zum Beispiel nicht haben wollten, ist, dass Flash in der CPU eingebaut ist, weil der Flash-Speicherbaustein muss speziell geschützt werden im Weltraum. Und wenn das in der CPU der Fall ist, dann muss man diese Abschirmung, dieser kleine Bereich, der abgeschirmt ist mit dem Flash-Speicher, größer machen, sodass er auch die CPU abdeckt. Und diese Abschirmung braucht ja Platz. Also da waren gewisse Anforderungen natürlich an die ganze Elektronik, geringer Stromverbrauch, so gesagt Schichten wie Brownout Detection und so weiter, was da halt technisch noch dazu kommt. Ja, das bedeutet nichts anderes, als dass die CPU auch sauber wieder hochkommt, nachdem irgendwelche Spannungsschwankungen in der Stromversorgung da waren. Also es kann ja in so einem Satelliten-Tour erstmal vorkommen, wenn irgendwie die Batterie kaputt ist oder der Orbit gerade ungünstig, dass ich mal nicht genug Spannung habe, um das Ding, um das System aufrecht zu erhalten. Und dann muss natürlich die CPU sauber wieder hochkommen. Manche CPUs tun das ohne externe Reset, ohne externe Resetschaltung. Manche CPUs brauchen dazu eine. Das ist dann eben diese Brownout-Detection. Und auf solche Geschichten muss man natürlich achten.
Ja, super.
Ein 10 x 10 x 10 cm großer Satellit. Das ist so ziemlich das Verblüffendste, was ich seit langem gehört habe.
Ja, das ist ganz, das ist, das ist, das ist, also fast, es gibt ein bisschen kleinere sogar noch.
Bitte, mein Gehirn ist jetzt schon überfordert.
Wir schießen ein Handy in den Orbit.
Ja, das könnt ihr auch machen. Wir haben uns das sogar mal überlegt. Also wir hatten uns am Anfang sogar überlegt, einfach ein PDA oder ein Handy zu kaufen, das Display und den Kram wegzuschmeißen und quasi die Elektronik im Satelliten zu verwenden.
Und?
Wurde aber verworfen, weil wir das nicht schalt montieren können und weil wir damit durch die Vibrations-Tests und so weiter nicht gekommen wären.
Thomas, ich bin, also ich bin, also der, der, der, der, der Laie wundert sich, also ich und der Fachmann staunt, das sind Harald und Tim. Sag nochmal, wann das Ding hochgeschossen wird.
27. September.
Viel Erfolg dann.
Dankeschön.
Womit geht das Ding hoch?
Mit einer russischen Rakete in Baikonur.
Super.
Vom Kosmodrom.
Ja, viel Erfolg beim Würfel.
Gott, Würfel nicht.
Würfel werfen.
Großes Kino.
Vielen Dank für deinen Anruf Thomas.
Ja, gerne.
Chaosradio 105.
Interessanter Trend, also so kleinere werdende Satelliten, das ist ja auch in der ganzen Weltraumtechnik und überhaupt. Embedded Technik und diese Reliability-Geschichte ist gerade natürlich in der Weltraumtechnik ein echtes Thema. Also die ersten Embedded-Systeme wurden unter anderem auch bei den Mondlandeprojekten, Apollo-Mondlandeprojekten eingesetzt. Dieser Lunar Lander, der auf dem Mond aufgesetzt ist, war im Prinzip schon von so einem Embedded-Prozessor ganz einfacher Natur, aber eben schon intelligent gesteuert, weil die konnten ja nicht über diese lange Strecke in irgendeiner Form eine Fernsteuerung machen. Trotzdem brauchte man eben auch etwas, was sofort reagiert, was also auch die Astronauten selber nicht hätten tun können. Und das ist eben genau der Moment, wo man so intelligente Steuerungen verwendet. Und der erste, daran erinnere ich mich immer gerne, der erste Prozessor, den ich überhaupt selber mal so direkt programmiert habe, der im Prinzip so als Embedded-Prozessor auch verwendet wird, das war dasselbe Modell, was auch in der Voyager mittlerweile unser Solarsystem verlassen hat. Also da ist halt auch so ein Prozessor drin und der wurde halt deshalb ausgewählt, weil er eben, daran wurde ich eben gerade erinnert, wo er das gesagt hat, weil er eben geeignet war, diese starken Kosmosstrahlung auszuhalten.
Das war der RCA 1802.
Ich hab jetzt gerade die Geigen nicht da, aber spielen wir das nächste.
Ich brauch noch eine Core-Tasse.
Ja, Embedded Systems das Thema im Chaosradio 105 und Thomas Berlin, der entwickelt selber solche Sachen.
Genau, ich bin natürlich auch umgeben von so einem Zeug. Ich hab auch so ein PDA und ich hab so einen MP3-Player. Aber ich wollte nur sagen, wer sich damit genauer beschäftigen will und mal ganz unten anfangen will, es gibt ein wirklich tolles Buch von dem Andreas Roth. Das nennt sich das Mikrocontroller Kochbuch. Da wird einem so richtig von Grund auf ohne Betriebssystem, ohne große PC-Kennnisse beigebracht, wie man sowas programmieren kann.
Ja, das ist so. Wie ich vorhin schon erwähnt habe, so ein bisschen die Elektronikerschiene sozusagen, also der Zugang zu der Materie für Leute, die einen Elektronikhintergrund irgendwie haben, und sich damit auskennen, die dann sicherlich auf solche Systeme gut einsteigen können.
Ja, also ich fand das Buch halt unglaublich klasse, weil ich damals noch nicht so viel Erfahrung mit dem PC hatte. Man kann es wirklich lernen und man lernt dann auch. Also klar, wenn du irgendein Programm in C schreibst, da kommt irgendwann ja am Ende Maschinencode raus. Aber so richtig genau, was passiert, kapiert eigentlich, da kapieren wenige Leute. Und wenn du so ein Buch mal durchgeackert hast und dann mit rum experimentierst hast, dann weißt du auch, was in deinem PC so funktioniert und abläuft. Und dann weißt du auch, wie komplex die ganze Sache werden kann. Also wenn man nun mal irgendwie so einen C-10-Zeiler nimmt und dann irgendwie mehrere Ks an Maschinencode rauskommen und du einfach nur wolltest, dass der irgendwie deine auf dem Balkon irgendwie deine Schanzen überwacht und gießt, wenn es notwendig ist und du das dann halt in 100 Zeilen Assembler selbst schreiben kannst, dann weißt du, was da auch für Schott bei rauskommen kann.
Aber da gibt es doch diese komischen Kügelchen, diese.
Ja, aber die zeigen mir nur, wann es Zeit ist zu gießen. Und die machen es nicht.
Die gießen ja nicht automatisch.
Na gut, dann nimmst du eben eine Wasserflasche, machst sie voll Wasser und stopfst sie umgekehrt in die Erde. Und wenn die Erde trocken wird, sickert Wasser nach.
Und wenn die Flasche leer ist?
Ihr seid immer so kleinkrämerisch, seid ihr manchmal.
Wenn man vier Wochen im Urlaub ist irgendwo und einfach einen, weiß ich nicht, 80 Liter Tank auf den Balkon stellen kann, dann ist das schon ein schöner.
Ja, ist ja gut.
Außerdem, also mein, also nicht Spezialgebiet, also was ich völlig faszinierend finde, was man auch schon mit Assembler, wenn man ein bisschen fit ist und wenn man sich ein bisschen mit beschäftigt, was man dann wirklich tun kann. Also ich hab diverse autonome mobile Roboter hier, die so irgendwas tun oder auch nicht.
Wie irgendwas was?
Na ich hab vor ungefähr, als ich hier in eine neue Wohnung gezogen bin vor zwölf Jahren, war die ziemlich groß und dann hab ich gedacht, Staubsaugen will ich die einfach nicht, macht mir Stress. Und dann hab ich so einen Staubsauger, der selbstständig staubsaugt. Also gibt's mittlerweile auch von der Industrie und alles, aber das tut ja einfach.
Entschuldigung, du hast dir sowas selbst gebaut?
Sowas kann man machen, ja.
Wahnsinn.
Hat's funktioniert?
Das funktioniert. Das funktioniert zwar, sagen wir mal so, es funktioniert insoweit, als dass er durch die Gegend fährt, selbstständig in die Ladestation fährt, sich auflädt. Was nicht so toll ist, ist so diese ganze Mechanik dabei. Also du musst dann irgendwie schon, also ich hab so einen einfachen Handstaubsauger für das Auto darauf geschraubt und der saugt halt nicht so effektiv, wie wenn du mit so einem Profi-Staubsauger, den du überall bei kaufen kannst, der Car starten.
Wo willst du auch die 1600 Watt her willkommen, wenn du nicht vom Akku spreist?
Na ja gut, der kann ja alle fünf Minuten meinetwegen an die Ladestation fahren. Also das wär nicht so das Problem, denke ich mal. Also das irgendwie... Also entscheidend...
Muss er nur seine Ladestation auch finden?
Ja, die findet er ja. Der weiß ja, wo er ist so ungefähr und den Rest orientiert er sich dann per Laser. Also da gibt es zwei Laser, die sagen ihm halt zwei Koordinaten, er muss bloß den Raum finden und dann kriegt er schon irgendwie hin. Aber entscheidend ist nicht so sehr, dass das Ding nachher einem wirklich Arbeit abnimmt, sondern dass man das wirklich, also wenn du was in Assembler programmierst, dass du völlig blickst, was da drin passiert. Das finde ich so faszinierend, wenn ich in C-Basic oder was es auch immer für Programmiersprachen gibt, diese Hochsprachenprogramm schreibe, dann tut das das auch. Aber ich weiß halt nicht 100% was innen drin funktioniert. Und damit also habe ich immer, ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich schreibe eher ein Programm in der Semmler als in einer Hochsprache und ich traue mich auch nicht so richtig an irgendeinen DVD-Player den aufzumachen, um da irgendwas zu verändern, weil das mir alles viel zu hoch ist. Auch diese Anleitung, die ich da im Internet finde, da wird halt nur gesagt, mach Bies, mach jenes und dann geht das schon oder spiel Linux auf deine D-Box und so. Aber ich weiß ja nicht was passiert.
Dann musst du es mal ausprobieren, dann weißt du das auch.
Ja, ich möchte halt wissen, was passiert und da kann ich nur jedem empfehlen, der sich wirklich mit Embedded Systems befassen will, wirklich bei Assembler anzufangen.
Und eine gute Nacht noch.
Sie auch, danke.
Das Buch, was er erwähnt hat, ist speziell für MCS51, was wiederum eine andere Bezeichnung von Intel ist, für die 8051 Prozessorserie. Das ist eine recht verbreitete Prozessor, klassische Prozessor-Serie für Embedded Prozessoren. Heutzutage gibt es natürlich auch noch sehr viel weitere, weitere sehr erfolgreiche und verbreitete Prozessor-Typen. Also gerade in diesen DSL-Routern heutzutage findet man eher MIPS- und ARM-Prozessoren, teilweise halt auch schon komplette PCs, also die auch tatsächlich denselben Instruktionssatz haben, wie so ein normaler Desktop-PC. Also Mikrocontroller, die quasi letztlich dasselbe machen. Da gibt es verschiedenste Hersteller, AMD baut sowas, andere auch. Und ist letztlich egal. Also ich finde diesen Ansatz mit Assembler und ich gehe jetzt bis ganz nach unten, finde ich okay, kann ich nachvollziehen. Auf der anderen Seite macht es durchaus Sinn, in Hochsprachen zu programmieren, wenn man das kann. Da geht einem jetzt nicht so viel verloren. Wenn man mit sowas ganz einfachen arbeitet, wie diesen PIX und den Atmel-Prozessoren, die vorhin im Gespräch waren, dann möchte man das auch tatsächlich auf dem Niveau machen.
Auch 8051 ist etwas, was man noch gut von Hand in Assembler handhaben kann. Sehr übersichtlich, aber wenn ich jetzt zu größeren Prozessoren hingehe, einfach weil ich mehr Leistungsfähigkeit brauche, dann will ich nicht alles irgendwie, das ist dann auch nichts mehr, was ein Mensch alleine schaffen kann, dann will ich nicht alleine jedes einzelne Bit irgendwo hinfummeln, sondern dann nimmt man eben Hochsprache. Und die Argumentation mit Assembler und dergleichen, die gilt genauso für, sagen wir, Betriebssystementwicklung am PC, ist es genau das gleiche. Also wer tatsächlich irgendwie im Linux-Könnel oder in einem anderen VST oder was auch immer in irgendeinem Betriebssystem selber etwas entwickeln will, also nicht auf dem Betriebssystem, sondern in dem Betriebssystem, der wird nicht umhinkommen, auf sehr niedriger Ebene zu verstehen, was die Hardware da tut und eben mal zu gucken, was für Assembler spuckt denn der Compiler eigentlich aus am Ergebnis. Aber gut, also Embedded Systems.
Ihr Chaosradio 105, es geht um Embedded Systems und Andreas aus Berlin versucht es nochmal.
Ja, ich hätte zum Themabeitrag tatsächlich zu liefern, zwar nicht ganz so stark wie der junge Mann mit dem 10x10cm-Satelliten, das war ja schon echt der Knüller. Ja, ich hätte jetzt mal so rein theoretisch die Spekulation, wie weit eigentlich die Cash-Karten gehen werden. Oder die Karten mit den kleinen Transponders und sowas. Das ist ja nun auch wirklich hochinteressant, ob man sich später noch, ob man sich in der Zukunft noch sicher sein kann, nicht unter eine Art Kontrolle zu fallen.
Da bringst du natürlich jetzt ganz viele Themen auf einmal auf. Auf der einen Seite ist natürlich der Hinweis schon mal sehr gut. Auch diese Chipkarten kann man im Prinzip als Embedded Systems begreifen, weil da ist halt auch ein Prozessor drauf. Die können ja schon so richtig Kryptographie und die reagieren ja auch auf Expertenfragen. Genau, da war man C64 nicht so schnell wie diese Chipkarten heute.
Also auch wenn man sich diese typische Chipkarten ansieht, zum Beispiel die Gesundheitskarte im österreichischen Gesundheitswesen, die eingeführt worden ist seit dem 1.1. dieses Jahres. Das ist also eine richtige Prozessorchipkarte, ist ein komplettes Embedded-System, das hat Hardwarebeschleunigte Kryptographie, da ist ein Betriebssystem drauf, es ist nun wirklich ein kompletter Rechner in einer Karte drin. Ähnliches wird uns blühen ab Oktober, wenn es denn klappt, mit unseren neuen biometrischen Reisepassen. Da sind also auch Embedded-Systeme drin. Es ist also letztendlich ein Mikro-Controller, der da drin ist, mit dem Funkinterface, also diese RFID-Geschichte. Ebenfalls mit Hardware-Kryptographie, mit eigenem Betriebssystem, mit Berechtigungsmanagement, also man hat da wirklich ein Permission-System, je nachdem, was genau jetzt für einen Controller zum Einsatz kommt, aber auch mit Memory-Management-Unit. Was man von großen Systemen kennt, ist dort alles in den Karten drin. Das heißt, wir werden in Zukunft, wenn wir unseren Reisepass zücken, unser Embedded-System aus der Tasche nehmen.
Aus der Blei-verkleideten Tasche.
Dass mich das irgendwie so ein bisschen besorgt. Weil man weiß ja nicht jetzt, was daraus alles so gesammelt wird. Also jetzt haben wir ganz schwach gesagt, man wird ja einfach kontrolliert und das weiß man eigentlich schon seit lang. Und von daher wollte ich es einfach mal zur Sprache bringen, dass das doch auch irgendwie doch mal ein bisschen in Betracht gezogen werden muss. Dass man doch wirklich in den kleinsten Dingen des Alltags doch schon eine Art Überwachung erlebt.
Sicher. Also wir haben ja auch hier im CCC eines unserer wichtigen Themen ist ja gerade die Privatsphäre und gerade in der digitalen Welt. Wir befassen uns ja auch mit Themen wie Videoüberwachung und Lawful Interception, also zum Abhören von Telefonen. Und dergleichen hatten wir auch schon Chaosradio-Sendungen.
Das ist eigentlich alles irgendwie die gleiche Schiene. Aber jetzt zu dem System, wie klein das sein kann, so ein ganz klein unbescheinbarer Schiff, dass man so eine Art Empfang und Empfänger hat. Und man weiß gar nichts davon.
Allerdings nicht ganz Thema dieser Sendung, sondern hier geht es dann doch eher um die Systeme selbst und nicht um die Auswirkungen dieser Systeme.
Ja, um die komplette Komplette. Aber im Prinzip fängt es auch da schon an.
Nee, da fängt es nicht an. Andreas, da fängt es nicht an. Sondern es ist eine Anwendung von Embedded Systems. Und um Embedded Systems geht es nicht um die Anwendung, also nicht um Überwachung. Du rufst dummerweise zum falschen Thema an. Aber trotzdem danke, weil ein Stichwort war dabei, das wir benutzen konnten, und zwar diese Chips in Personalausweisen.
Ja, dass man die so klein umgeachtet lässt, und dabei sind die doch schon ganz schön kompliziert geworden.
Genau.
Danke für deinen Anruf, Andreas. Chaosradio 105er Fritz, es geht um Embedded Systems heute Abend.
Fritz in Neukölln, dann 102, 6.
Genau, 12.
Fritz Info.
Heute Nacht ist es gering bewölkt oder starrenklar. Es kühlt sich allerdings ab auf 16 bis 10 Grad. Morgen wird es dann wieder schön, die Sonne scheint und die Temperaturen steigen auf 27 bis 30 Grad. Hier sind die Meldungen mit Matthias Karkos.
Nach dem Durchzug des Wirbelsturms Katharina werden im Golf von Mexiko 20 Ölplattformen vermisst. Außerdem stehe eine gebrochene Gaspipeline in Flammen, meldet die amerikanische Küstenwache. Es kamen zu Preiserhöhungen und langen Autoschlangen für den Tankstellen. Auch in Deutschland sind die Benzinpreisen bisher nicht gekanntem Ausmaß gestiegen. Präsident Bush will beim Kongress einen Sonderfonds für die Opfer des Hauiken beantragen. Die Lage an der Südküste wird immer dramatischer. Im schon überfluteten New Orleans steigt das Wasser nach mehreren Dammbrüchen immer weiter. Plünderungen sind zur Normalität geworden. Die Stadt soll vollständig evakuiert werden. In der irakischen Hauptstadt Bagdad sind bei einer Massenpanik auf einer Brücke bis zu 1.000 Menschen ums Leben gekommen. Ausgelöst wurde die Panik durch Gerüchte über einen bevorstehenden Selbstmordanstark. Der brandenburgische CDU-Chef Schönbohm will bis 2009 im Amt bleiben. Das kündigte Schönbohm der Tageszeitung Die Welt an. Nach seinen umstrittenen Äußerungen über die Folgen des DDR-Systems war spekuliert worden, dass er bereits 2007 den Parteivorsitz abgeliefert hat. Der Verkehrer Fritz hat keine Meldungen, deshalb weiter. Gute Fahrt.
Fritz, eine Produktion des RBB.
Oder das.
Kann man im Fritz Club rausfinden. Fritz präsentiert die Heißer Chiefs live in Berlin. Donnerstag, 8. September, ab 20 Uhr, im Fritz Club im Postbahnhof. Direkt am Berliner Ostbahnhof. Die Heißer Chiefs live und im Radio. Fritz!
Ja, Chaos Radio 105 auf Fritz. Es geht um Embedded Systems. Das sind die Computer, die unter anderem mit neuen Waschmaschinen sind, vorausgesetzt, die haben moderne Waschmaschinen und nicht die, die ähnlichen Schalter haben wie in den 70er Jahren Fernseher. Ja, auch diese komischen Ratschknack-Schalter.
Ich kenne auch noch Videorekorder, bei denen tatsächlich man mechanisch so die Köpfe ins Band hineingedrückt hat.
Video 2000, ne?
Nee, auch bei VHS bei dem ersten. Jaja, das war wie so ein Kassettenrekorder. Also da geht so die Klappe auf und man schiebt die Kassette rein.
Alles sehr mechanisch noch, alles sehr akan.
Hat aber auch funktioniert.
Ja, ist vielleicht sogar EMP-safe.
Also zumindest hat die Software immer zuverlässiger funktioniert.
Ja, war keine drin.
Ja, oder sie war halt so minimalistisch, dass man da eben noch Fehler machen konnte, aber das ist halt jetzt eben anders. Aber darauf müssen wir uns jetzt eben einstellen. Also die Welt ändert sich und alles ist Software. Also man kann halt einfach mit Software jetzt sehr viel mehr tun. Man kann natürlich auch sehr viel mehr falsch tun. Und an der Stelle brauchen wir ohnehin jetzt nochmal so eine Phase von 10, 20 Jahren, wo diese Welt lernen muss, dass es nicht nur reicht, irgendwas zu programmieren, sondern wo man auch mal vorher drüber nachdenken muss, wie man denn das am besten tut. Da gehen die Meinungen natürlich sehr weit auseinander. Aber Softwarequalität ist noch nicht so ein erkanntes Problem wie Umweltbewusstsein.
Vor allem nicht im Embedded-System-Bereich. Man muss da trennen zwischen dem industriellen Embedded-Bereich und zwischen dem Consumer-Embedded-Bereich. Und im Consumer-Markt zählt halt einfach nur der Preis. Also irgendwie dieser CD-Player oder Videorekorder oder was auch immer, das Handy muss einfach so billig wie möglich sein, damit die Leute auch kaufen in Millionen und die werden eh in zwei oder drei Jahren weggeworfen. Und so denkt auch die Entwicklungsabteilung, die dahintersteht. Also da wird Software entwickelt in Wegwerfmanier. Die wird einfach hingerotzt, so schnell wie möglich, ohne dass man auf Qualität achtet und dann sind da natürlich auch dementsprechend viele Bugs drin. Und die ganzen Viren-Würmer-Exploits und Sicherheitsprobleme, die wir aus der PC-Welt oder überhaupt aus der Computerwelt kennen, die greifen dann eben die Smartphones an, die sich jetzt gerade breit machen oder es gibt auch schon über Bluetooth Sicherheitslöcher bei Telefonen. Alles, was irgendwo vernetzt ist und in Kommunikation steht und komplexe Software läuft, ist anfällig dafür. Und wer denkt schon daran, dass er irgendwie seinen DSL-Router updaten muss, weil er sonst exploited wird oder irgend sowas?
Die Industrie spricht von rentabler Sicherheit. Das finde ich einen ganz tollen Begriff. Ja, ja, schon bei Banking Software gibt es so. Da ist Gott sei Dank die Rentabilität früh in Gefahr. Wenn die Sicherheit nicht stimmt, das haben sie mittlerweile eingesehen, aber bei anderen ist es eben nicht so ein gutes Beispiel. Es ist diese Bluetooth-Geschichte, die vor einem anderthalb Jahr knapp zwei Jahren rauskam. Letztes Jahr hatten wir da auf dem Kongressjahr auch den ersten Vortrag dazu, der das noch mal ausführlich dokumentiert hat, wie das eigentlich lief. Also es hat jemand eine Schwachstelle gefunden in sehr vielen Mobiltelefonen. Über Bluetooth konnte man eben problemlos ohne irgendwie Eingabe von irgendwelchen Passworten oder so direkt an die Daten ran. Also man konnte das Adressbuch auslesen. Man konnte SMS verschicken auf Kosten des Eigentümers, in dem man einfach nur mit seinem Telefon durch U-Bahn-Stationen gelaufen ist. Und jemand konnte halt mit einem Laptop aus 100 Meter, 50 Meter Entfernung halt einfach alles auslesen.
Wobei das ja immer noch, das setzt ja immer noch voraus, dass die Leute ihr Bluetooth permanent eingeschaltet haben.
Ja, aber haben sie.
Haben sie?
Ja, nicht alle, aber viele.
Genug.
Viele genug, so. Und ja, gut, sagen wir mal, dass jetzt so ein Gerät so ein Fehler hat, das finde ich ja gar nicht so bedrohlich. Das kann ja passieren. Nur, er ist dann halt zu den Firmen hingegangen und hat gesagt, hier, ich habe das gefunden, ich werde euch ja auch erzählen, wie es funktioniert. Das wollten die erst mal gar nicht hören. Und ich weiß ja nicht genau, wie das im Einzelnen gelaufen ist. Am Schluss war er auf jeden Fall ausreichend frustriert. Keiner hat das halt irgendwie behoben, weil die alle der Meinung waren, wie du eben schon richtig gesagt hast, wieso, in zwei Jahren kommen die sich sowieso alle neue Geräte. Das ist halt für uns nicht rentabel. Und ich kenne also überhaupt derzeit noch von eigentlich keinem einzigen Mobiltelefon, wo man wirklich im Internet mal sich ein Update holen kann. Und das lädt man dann runter. Nein, da muss man zum Händler gehen, wo dann irgendwelche bekloppten PC stehen.
Ich erinnere mich daran, dass ich mal ein Siemens-Handy geupdatet habe übers Netz. Also runterladen, Datenkabel dran.
Gut so. Und wird auch wieder kommen, wenn wir alle... Ja, es wird vielleicht noch Siemens heißen, aber nicht mehr Siemens gehören. Aber nötig ist das, so wie das ja heutzutage selbstverständlich ist. So ein Mac oder ein Windows holt sich ja seine Daten auch übers Internet und die könnten ja schon gar nicht mehr funktionieren, wenn es das Internet nicht gäbe. Also zumindest wären sie nicht in der Lage, diese Innovationsgeschwindigkeit aufrecht zu erhalten, wenn sie nicht auch die Möglichkeit hätten, in der gleichen Geschwindigkeit Fehler zu beheben. Allein diese ganzen Sicherheitsupdates, die reinkommen, weil wieder in irgendeinem bekloppten Tool, Open Source oder nicht, halt eine Lücke gefunden wurde. Und das ist auch richtig so und daran müssen wir uns auch gewöhnen, dass diese vernetzten Geräte werden einfach die Normalität darstellen und wir werden uns dabei erwischen, wie wir sonntags unseren Kühlschrank neue Firmware verpassen, weil, keine Ahnung. Der Kühlschrank, ja, das ist, genau, das hatten wir schon in der Vorbesprechung.
Der Kühlschrank ist ja dieses ominöse Gerät.
Also, wenn auch immer von Internet, genau, der Internet Kühlschrank, immer wird davon geredet, so ein bisschen wie mit Sex in der Küche. Jeder redet ja lieber, ja, aber keiner macht's. Offensichtlich spielt sich immer eine Menge in der Küche ab. Man kennt das ja von Partys. Aber dieser Kühlschrank will einfach nicht so richtig digital werden, obwohl es da so zahlreiche Ideen und Prototypen gab mit Webcam in den Kühlschrank und so. Letztlich will das eh dann ja keiner sehen. Oder halt mit dem Kühlschrank, der selbst nachbestellt. Wobei ehrlich gesagt, würde ich das ja lieber selber machen, als es mal im Kühlschrank zu erlassen. Von daher denke ich, man wird sich das noch nicht so ganz durchsetzen. Aber vielleicht im Hinblick auf Stromsparen und so weiter wird halt auch diese ganze elektronische Steuerung dort weiter Fuß fasst.
Aber die bestellen nicht. Was fängt das Ding irgendwann an, mit dir darüber reden zu wollen, dass da ein bisschen viel Schoki in der letzten Woche durchgelaufen ist?
Du musst wahrscheinlich deiner Glühbirne demnächst noch psychologisch unterstützen.
Den Film?
Nee, nicht gesehen.
Ah, nicht gesehen.
Welchen Film?
The Island.
Hab ich auch nicht gesehen.
Ah.
Okay, erzähl.
Na, da steht man in der Früh auf und dann uriniert man halt des Morgens und dann wird das gleich analysiert und dann wird festgestellt, ah, die und die Werte sind gar schlecht, da gibt's kein Bacon zum Frühstück. Und solche Sachen.
Das ist ja mal praktisch. Also das finde ich praktisch.
Klingt japanisch.
Ich will es nicht haben, aber praktisch ist es. Ja, das ist genau wie diese Toiletten, die die Japaner haben.
Ah, die sind da irgendwie, ich weiß auch nicht wie die sind, aber die sind so.
Embedded Toiletten. Angerufen hat außerdem FD01.
Na, hör damit.
Ja, hallo?
Moin moin. Achso, hier steht FD01 bei mir.
Ja, das ist nicht so schlimm, euer Frontmensch hat das glaube ich nicht so ganz richtig verstanden.
FD0 der Einzige heißt das.
Der Erste.
Genau, ich hab auf der Web der Hack, da gab's noch einen anderen FD01, das war sehr irritierend mit dem zu irkeln, also egal. Zu den Siemens-Handys nochmal, ich hatte letztens ein Siemens-Handy, das hatte diesen Punkt Live-Update über GPHS, CMA, eine neue Firmware. Das hab ich aber nicht gemacht, weil ich hab schlechte Erfahrungen gemacht mit Firmware-Updates von Siemens. Aber gut, weshalb ich anrufe? Ich hab mir vor einem halben Jahr überlegt, dass ich irgendwie gerne mein Zimmer beleuchten möchte, also mein Apartment, wo ich wohne. Und das ist ja irgendwie, also bei Standard-Camps hat man ja schon hinter sich in diese Schwarzlichtröhren und ein Deckenfluter und so weiter und ich möchte gerne irgendwie eine Lampe haben, der ich je nach Laune gerade sagen kann, dass ich für eine Farbe machen soll. Am besten davon auch mehrere, die dann intelligent anzusteuern sind. Im Endausbau dann irgendwie mit so einem Gerät an der Wand, wo halt am besten kein PC mehr dran hängt, damit das auch funktioniert. Hab dann angefangen, ein bisschen rumzusuchen, hab mich da eingearbeitet und rausgekommen ist das Snorflicht. So haben wir das mal getauscht.
Stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp.
Ja?
Das war jetzt am Telefon nicht so gut. Hast du Fnordlicht gesagt?
Genau.
Ich liebe dich.
Es war noch nicht mal meine Idee, sondern es war die Idee vom Lars, mit dem ich das zusammen entwickelt habe.
Eigentlich müsste ein Licht ja illuminieren.
Ja, also wir sind noch ein bisschen flexibel.
Da wird auch noch weiter was vorkommen.
Mittlerweile ist das auch ein Projekt von Köln CCC.de. Da gibt es auch eine Projektwebseite, köln.ccc.de slash Prozesse slash Running slash Snorflicht. Wenn man sich da ein bisschen durchklickt oder sucht, findet man das auch. Da gibt es auch ein paar Fotos. Das Ganze ist aufgebaut auf einem Art-Mail-Controller. Und kann mittlerweile, also rein rechnerisch, kann es 16 Millionen Farben darstellen. Ich hab also mit LEDs das Ganze, mit roten, grünen, blauen LEDs, und dann Farbmischung gemacht. Und jeder Farbkanal kann 256 Helligkeitsstufen rein rechnerisch, die untersten 5 fallen weg, weil da gibt es einen Transistor, der ist zu langsam. Aber der macht schon sehr schöne Farben. Und dann haben wir halt angefangen, die Firmware aufzubohren. Und der Lars hat auch eine Firmware geschrieben, das wird demnächst auch integriert, die halt Multitasking-Skripts macht, also bis zu 10 Skripte parallel, die da irgendwas in der Farbe drehen. Und das Ding soll über i2c kommunizieren. Das heißt, ich will im Endausbau auch solche Dinger zusammenstecken können und mit denen Hardware-mäßig Game of Life oder so spielen, diese Zellautomaten-Simulation. Und das ist mit einem Atmega8 geschrieben, der hat einen Kilobyte RAM, 8 KB Flash und 512 Byte EEPROM. Und die gesamte Firmware, inklusive dem Skript-Interpreter, so wie er jetzt ist, sind 2, 5 KB. Das heißt, wir haben da noch jede Menge freien Platz. Das würde ich jedem raten, auch mal so ein Projekt zu machen, dass man lernt unglaublich viel über die ganzen Hardware-Dinge.
Ich würde vor allem jedem raten, auf diese Webseite zu klicken, weil die Fotos, die er gemacht hat, die sind ja ganz hübsch und sehr ausführlich. Schön viel kleiner LED-Porn und auch sehr hübsche Farbgebungen, die dabei rausgekommen ist.
Köln.cdc.de, dann einfach auf den ersten Hit klicken.
Macht ihr für die LEDs dann PWM?
Genau, richtig. Also LEDs kann man nicht dimmen über die angelegte Spannung. Das funktioniert halt in einem Bereich. Das erste Problem ist, dass LEDs sehr unterschiedlich sind. Und gerade auch in diesem Helligkeitsbereich, die haben halt jeweils eine andere Spannung. Das heißt, man steuert die an, indem man ihnen 20 mA Strom gibt und dann leuchten die. Und darüber kann man sie aber nicht dimmen, sondern man lässt sie im Prinzip flackern. Und in dem Verhältnis von Einschalt- zu Ausschaltzeit, dadurch kann man die Helligkeit bestimmen. Das Problem ist, das Auge ist ein bisschen blöd. Das heißt, es nimmt flackernde LEDs wesentlich heller wahr, als sie eigentlich der Photonenausbeute nach sind. Ist auf dieser Webseite auch alles erklärt. Da muss man eine Gamma-Korrektur machen, hat dann kein linkes Verhältnis, sondern etwa ein quadratisches Verhältnis. Das tut sie nicht gut. Und dann macht man PWM, also Pulsweitenmodulation, und dimmt im Prinzip über das Verhältnis von Einschalt zu Ausschaltzeit. Das war eine recht spannende Sache, weil dadurch, dass ich 56 Helligkeitsstufen pro Fahrtkanal haben wollte, kam es bei diesem ATMEGA8, der mit 16 MHz getaktet wurde, kam es in den unteren Bereichen teilweise auf 2 bis 5 Taktzyklen an, in denen dann ein Kanal an- oder aus sein muss. Das war relativ kitzlig, das zu realisieren.
Ja, ist auch sicherlich interessant, was das dann für eine Störstrahlung in den Divertenfrequenzbinder nachgibt.
Ja, ich bin mal gespannt. Wir haben uns jetzt überlegt, das auch als Jugendprojekt zu machen. In Köln gibt es jedes Jahr ein Jugendprojekt namens U23. Wir ziehen das gerade auf, dass wir das mit Leuten löten und dann mal gucken, je nachdem, was das für eine Gruppe wird, können die halt an der Firmware rumpacken, wenn sie wollen, oder können Ansteuersoftware schreiben. Lars und ich sitzen eigentlich auch gerade zusammen und hören Chaosradio und die wagen nebenbei die Ansteuerung für I4C. Und mal gucken, je nachdem, was für eine Gruppe es ist, kann auch sein, dass da ein netter Ansteuerungssoftware rausfällt. Also Pallas aus Köln hat auch mal schon angekündigt, sie würde gerne einen kleinen Flashfrontend schreiben, womit man dann so Farbverläufe zusammenklicken kann, die man dann statisch in den Protester reinschiebt, die er dann einfach abspielt beim Einschalten oder so. Und ich bin mal gespannt, was dabei rauskommt.
Umfangreiches Blinkengebastel, ja, das hat ja mittlerweile Tradition im CCC. Macht ihr das dann auch über das Netzwerk ansprechbar?
Ja, das Problem ist, dass man Netzwerkchips in ordentlich belötbar nicht bekommen. Das heißt, das sind immer SMD-Teile. Und das ist so ein bisschen noch ein Problem.
SMD kann man doch schön löten, was habt ihr denn?
Ja, ist schon in Ordnung. Also ich bin nicht so ein ganz so ein guter Löter. Wenn wir das halt als Projekt für Jugendliche macht, die irgendwie noch gar nicht gelötet haben, dann geht das schon mal gar nicht so toll. Dann gibt es noch die Möglichkeit, wir haben vor ein paar Jahren ein Projekt gehabt, wo wir Chips zur Verfügung gestellt haben von IPC. Das sind so kleine Dinger, die haben so einen Embedded Web Server da drauf und da haben sie dann gleich einen eQuadrat C Anschluss und so ein paar IO-Pinne und eine dirille Modem-Verbindung. Und die sind ganz süß eigentlich, weil man kann man auch per FDP dann das Programm hochladen, das ist auf 386er Basis. Aber das Problem ist, dass es für benutzbare Betriebssysteme TM keinen ordentlichen DOS-Compiler mehr gibt, dass man dafür dann irgendwie auch ein Windows wieder braucht oder einen DOS braucht am besten, um so einen DOS-Compiler zu instellen, um dafür Programme zu entwickeln. Und sonst in kleinen Boxen haben wir noch drei Stück. Dann müssen wir mal gucken, ob wir vielleicht damit auch irgendwas bauen, dass man den Kölner Clipraum dann demnächst irgendwie über eine Webseite halt die Farben einstellen kann, was er da gerade für Farben macht oder so. Denkbar wäre auch so eine Sache, dass man einfach einen Plug-in nimmt für XMMS oder sowas und dann versucht, aus einem Musikstück, was gerade läuft, Farben zu generieren. Und zwar nicht nur für eine Lampe, sondern für ganz viele.
Das geht aber auch notfalls mit Tabletten.
Schön. Ja, Netz-LSD. Netz-LSD. Super, ich hab ja ein Faible für solche Lichtsachen. Sehr schöner Name im Übrigen, schöne Fotos auch.
Die hat der Cephalon gemacht, der kann sowas. Ansonsten, das werden wir natürlich alles. Also das Platinlayout wird als Creative Commons, wahrscheinlich non-commercial, freigegeben werden. Die Software, also die Firmware dafür soll unter einer Open-Source-Lizenz auch freigegeben werden. Das kann man sich noch nachbauen hören möchte.
Super.
Der Link ist auch schon auf der Wikipedia-Seite zur Sendung. Alles geht seinen Lauf.
Vielen Dank, FT0.
Tschüss.
Ich hab im Wesentlichen gar nicht verstanden, worum es ging, aber das sieht cool aus.
Es sieht super aus.
Na ja, also Lichtsteuerung, das ist natürlich ein Thema. Wir hatten das ja auch bei unserem Blinken-Lights-Projekt. Also eine Lampe an- und auszumachen, das ist halt noch relativ einfach. Als wir das hier in Berlin gemacht haben, da hatten wir einfach stinknormale Relais, wo also noch so mechanisch Teile zusammengezogen werden, magnetisch, um dann irgendwie Licht an, Licht auszumachen. Aber wenn man eben in sowas hingeht, in Helligkeitssteuerung, dann wird es bei Licht schon ein bisschen tricky. LEDs sind relativ einfach noch anzusteuern, weil sich das alles sehr linear verhält. Das hat er auch beschrieben, da sind Experimente. Man dimmt eine LED dadurch, dass man sie eben innerhalb einer Sekunde einfach so und so viel Prozent der Zeit ausmacht und so und so viel Prozent der Zeit an. Aber halt nicht erst aus und dann an, weil dann würde es ja blinken, sondern man macht das halt in sehr, sehr kleinen Schritten. Eine hundertstel Sekunde reicht da eigentlich völlig aus. Dann machst du halt jede zweite hundertstel Sekunde an, dann machst du wieder aus und dann hast du halt 50 Prozent in etwa. So muss man mal gucken, wie der Wirkungsgrad von der LED ist.
Aber im Prinzip funktioniert das prima.
Das hatten wir auch schon bei diesem kleinen Bauschild, was wir eine Weile nach dem Projekt dann noch hatten, was das Ganze so in diesem Bauschild noch simuliert hat, auch gemacht. Das ist ganz nett. Also LEDs kosten natürlich auch ein bisschen was, wenn die schick sind. Aber damit kann man auf jeden Fall super Sachen bauen. Wenn man so eine ganz normale Glühbirne hat, dann wird das ein bisschen schwieriger. Harald hat das ja eben erwähnt. Also Pulsweitenmodulationen, Strom fließt ja da so wie so eine Sinuswelle da vor sich her. Also es kommt in Wellen, so ist der Strom. Und wenn man dann so eine stark nachglühende Wolfram-Wende dimmen möchte, dann muss man dann eben schon ein bisschen intelligenter damit rumtricksen. Und da sind natürlich auch Embedded-Systeme manchmal ganz hilfreich. Einfach als Steuermodul für Licht. Sowas gibt es auch für Leutstoffröhren, gibt es eben solche Embedded-Systeme, so kleine Schalter, Controller, die man davor baut, die eben eine intelligente Steuerung von Licht realisieren.
Auch wenn man in die professionelle Lichttechnik geht, im Disco-Bereich, Veranstaltungsbereich, das ist ja alles Embedded-Elektronik. Die ganzen Lampen müssen ja vorgeheizt werden, diese Glühfäden, damit sie dann auch möglichst schnell genug angehen. Also das ist eine ganze Wissenschaft für sich. Überhaupt der ganze Veranstaltungsbereich oder auch was wir hier im Radiostudio vor uns sehen, was ihr natürlich nicht sehen könnt, aber diese ganzen Mischpulte mit den LCD-Displays und LED-Displays und motorisierte Schieberegler und alles, ist ja alles Embedded-Systeme. Also wir sitzen hier in einem, wir sind das Embedded-System.
Wir sind Embedded Systems Embedded.
In Hildesheim, da sitzt einer, der kennt sich auch nicht aus, namens Rick. Du hast eine Laienfrage.
Ja, so richtig schöne Dummifrage. Also wir hatten das vorhin ja schon mal mit den neuen Reisepässen und den Chips drauf, ne? Was läuft denn da für ein Betriebssystem? Oder was nehmen die da für eine Software für? Ich mag es ja jetzt, ich will das als Betriebssystem bezeichnen, aber man stellt sich mal vor, da läuft so ein Microsoft-ähniges Produkt drauf und ich stehe da vor meinem Flieger, wir losfliegen, tja, aber mein...
Dein Pass ist abgestürzt, ne?
Die Betriebssysteme sind natürlich deutlich kleiner. Also diese, generell so die Dimension von Computer, die man in den Reisepässen drin hat, die Dimension von Embedded System, das ist also sowas, wo man, sagen wir mal, Größenordnung 32 Kilobyte ROM hat, sozusagen insgesamt für das Betriebssystem. Das ist also so wie Homecomputer vor 20, 25 Jahren oder so hatten. Natürlich waren die nicht fehlerfrei. Man versucht natürlich schon bei solchen sicherheitsrelevanten Betriebssystemen durch Zertifizierungen, durch Code-Auditing und so weiter eben hier die Sicherheit herzustellen. Natürlich ist es letztendlich Software. Natürlich könnte die auch letztendlich Fehler haben.
Allerdings geht es hier auch nicht um Microsoft.
Nur weil das Betriebssystem heißt, heißt das ja nicht, dass es irgendwie diese Komplexität hat. Also was irgendwie in 32 Kilowatt reinpasst, das ist ja doch noch verhältnismäßig überschaubar.
Das wird sich aber auch noch steigern. Da wird es ja nicht mehr bleiben, denke ich mal.
Ja, man muss schon irgendwo von irgendwas ausgehen bei einer Argumentation. Man kann jetzt nicht sagen, ja, aber das wird vielleicht und hier noch und da noch und so. Also die Ausweise, um die es im Moment geht, die haben eben so wenig. Und da ist ein relativ primitives Betriebssystem drin. Und das wird entsprechend auditiert und braucht eine EAL4 oder Höherzertifizierung für die Leute, denen das was sagt. Und dazu kommt ja auch, dass die sozusagen jedes Mal gebootet werden, wenn du sie in die Nähe eines Lesers bringst. Weil die sind ja aus, und nur wenn du sie in die Nähe des Lesers bringst, dann induziert dieser Laser über ein Magnetfeld überhaupt die Betriebsspannung in diesen Ausweis hinein. Und dadurch startet es ja sozusagen auch die ganze Zeit neu. Also diese ganzen Probleme, wenn Dinge sehr lange laufen und irgendwelche Sachen nicht mehr freigegeben werden oder speichern, gibt es alles gar nicht.
Gibt es da überhaupt die Möglichkeit reinzukriegen in so ein Ding?
Nein. Die Spezifikation für diese Reisefeste sagt aus, dass also die einmal beschrieben werden von der fast ausgebenden Stelle und danach sind die also nicht mal für die Behörden mehr beschreibbar. Sicherlich ja. Ich habe jetzt gerade kein Beispiel auf der Zunge, aber Bluetooth-Viren gab es ja auch schon.
Da geht es deswegen, oder?
Es hängt nicht so sehr davon ab, ob es embedded ist oder nicht.
Generell gilt das natürlich für jedes Betriebssystem. Ich muss immer ein bisschen schwer atmen, wenn ich diese Virusverstörungen höre. Wir hatten vor, ich glaube vor 10 Jahren, kam das erste Mal beim CCC so eine E-Mail an, die fragte, kann man den Viren per E-Mails verbreiten? Und wir bogen uns alle voll lachend in unseren Stühlen, sagten, nein, das ist total unmöglich, weil dann müsste ja jemand auf die Idee kommen und Code ausführen, den man mit einer E-Mail zugeschickt bekommt. Auf sowas würde ja wohl keiner kommen. Dass Microsoft das dann tatsächlich ein paar Jahre später tun würde und dass das so ein Drama ausortet, hätte sich keiner auch nur im geringsten vorstellen können. Von daher, möglich ist alles. Es ist sehr schwer, eine Aussage darüber zu machen, was die Sicherheitsprobleme von morgen sind. Außer denen, die sich heute bereits abzeichnen, weil die Technik im Prinzip schon angekündigt ist.
Wenn ich jetzt ein Firmenwerk abdecke und irgendwas einspiele, dass ich mir darüber einen einfange, ist doch generell gegeben. Und ich denke mal, abdeckfähig sein werden müssen die nächsten Generationen auf jeden Fall.
Auf jeden Fall. Wie heißt es immer so schön? Sicherheit ist kein Zustand, sondern ein Prozess. Man muss sich halt darüber Gedanken machen, was man so benutzt. Und deswegen machen wir ja auch diese Sendung. Wir wollen euch eigentlich nur klar machen, dass sehr viele dieser Geräte da draußen im Prinzip schon Computer sind, auch wenn sie nicht wie welche aussehen und man sie in zunehmenden Maße auch genauso misstrauisch beäugen sollte, wie man das auch heute schon ein Computer gegenüber tut. Da kommen noch sehr viel mehr schlimmes Zeug, das ist alles, das kann man fast gar nicht erzählen, ohne Anträge zu holen.
Hatten wir auch schon eine Chaosradio-Sendung dazu, wird auch sicher nicht die letzte gewesen sein.
Ich würde sagen, können wir endlose Chaosradios zu machen wahrscheinlich. Danke für deinen Anruf, Rick.
Jo, danke.
Gute Nacht.
Jo, tschau.
Und noch ein Embedded System, Achtung. Micha? Wo ist es drin?
Wie bitte?
Dein Embedded System ist wo drin?
Na hauptsächlich so in Modellmotoren, Elektromotoren oder eben auch Turbinen, Modellturbinen, die werden auch hauptsächlich von dem Embedded System überwacht.
Diese Autopiloten, also zumindest die Stabilität bei so ferngestellten Hubschraubern?
Ja, unter anderem auch. Aber hauptsächlich eben so, wo eben Regelelektronik eingesetzt werden muss, sprich, wenn zum Beispiel äußere Bedingungen geändert werden an der Turbine, zum Beispiel eine Turbine braucht auch eine Anlassphase oder eben ein Elektromotor ist jetzt seit einigen Jahren die Drehstromtechnik mit einzugehalten. Und da muss mehr oder weniger aus einer Gleichspannung und Gleichstrom ein Drehfeld erzeugt werden, was aber in dem Sinne auch nicht so einfach ist, weil ja Drehzahl steuert werden muss. Und nicht wie beim Ausnetz eben bloß 50 Herzt an Drehfeld ist. Oder auch ein Beispiel, die Fernsteuersender selber, die Signalaufbereitung, die wird heutzutage alles nicht mehr per Analogtechnik, so wie es eben vor 30 Jahren war. Oder wird viel mit Prozessoren gearbeitet, Signalmischung, Signalaufbereitung oder halt eben Signalumkehr.
Das ist ja nicht nur bei den kleinen Modellen so, sondern eben auch bei den großen. Also wenn man sich zum Beispiel U-Bahnen, Straßenbahnen dergleichen anschaut, da hat man auch diese Drehstrommotoren drin und die Phasenanschnittsteuerungen dazu und die Wechselrichter, die eben das entsprechende Feld erzeugen.
Also die Schwierigkeit bei den Elektromotoren besteht ja noch darin, dass die eben sensorlos laufen. Das heißt, da muss die Elektronik so intelligent sein, die unbestromten Phasen mehr oder weniger dazu zu benutzen, um eine Rückmeldung zu bekommen, wie rum der Motor eigentlich läuft und das ja auch in die richtige Richtung läuft. Und da finde ich das schon ein kleines Stück Entwicklergenie dahinter, um sowas erstmal herauszukriegen, so einen Regelkreis erstmal zu entwickeln. Ja, dass das auch sauber anläuft, alles in die richtige Richtung und ja.
Ist das deine Beschäftigung damit so im Wesentlichen?
Das ist so ein bisschen Elektronik-Bastelei, ich hab das halt eben über die Jahre mit verfolgt und es gibt wirklich ein paar Cracks, die dann anfangen sich halt eben einen Leiterplatten zu zeichnen oder das halt eben auch zu entwickeln und dann geben sie halt eben mal eine Kleinserie in Auftrag und sowas beobachte ich und wenn halt eben so eine Kleinserie im Entstehen ist, dann order ich mir halt eben die Platte und die Bauteile mit dazu und ja, dann kommt das Ding halt eben ins Flugmodell rein. Und es funktioniert, es macht Spaß. Ja, da ist auch dieser genannte AT-Mega-8 drauf, die der Kollege da schon genannt hatte, der Anrufer vor mir.
Und Faden verloren. Danke für deinen Anruf, Michael.
Ist auch für mich ein bisschen schwierig, weil ich hätte das erste Mal einen Radioanrufer, aber... Genau, nee, ich hab's bloß halt eben vorhin im Radio gehört, im Autoradio und dachte ich, vielleicht kann ich da so ein bisschen was mit beisteuern.
Super, das hast du getan. Vielen Dank, Michael.
Keine Ulsache, euch auch.
Chaos Radio 105 Embedded Systems, unser Thema heute hier in Blumenau-Frieds. Was?
Realtime.
Was ist Realtime?
Was ist Realtime? Das ist eine gute Frage.
Ich will nicht Meta, sondern was meinst du jetzt gerade in dem Moment?
Ich hab hier gerade aus dem Chat eine Zeile herausgepickt, die gerade in mir die Erinnerung wach rief, dass wir über Betriebssysteme noch einiges sagen wollten, die im Embedded Bereich verbreitet sind und da spielt natürlich auch Echtzeit eine Rolle auf englisch Realtime, einer der ganz tollen Begriffe, der schwer zu erklären ist.
Und egal welche Erklärung man ablief, man findet auf jeden Fall jemand, der widerspricht.
Aber wir hatten es ja vorhin schonmal angeschnitten, dass im Embedded Bereich andere Betriebssysteme zum Einsatz kommen, teilweise auch die gleichen, als die, die man jetzt auf Desktop-Computern findet. So schon erwähnt hatten wir, dass DOS, also das DOS von Microsoft, lange Zeit in diesem Embedded-Markt eine große Rolle gespielt hat. Natürlich für diese ganzen x86-basierten Sachen.
Dauert bis heute an. Also sogar die sehr populäre Canon EOS 300D Kamera zum Beispiel, also eine digitale Spiegelreflexkamera, so irgendwie High-End für Amateur oder für einen Privatgebrauch. Da läuft DOS drauf zum Beispiel.
Genau, aber es ist im Prinzip, also mein Eindruck ist, dass in diesem Embedded-Markt DOS ganz stark auf dem Rückzug ist. Das liegt natürlich da drin, dass DOS eben auch für viele moderne Anwendungen überhaupt nicht mehr die notwendigen Voraussetzungen bringt. Das eine ist halt Multitasking, das andere ist, dass natürlich auch sowas wie Speicherschutz heutzutage auch in dem Bereich manchmal schon eine Rolle spielt, aber vor allem ist es eben die fehlende Real-Time-Fähigkeit, die dort eine Rolle spielt und natürlich auch die Frage der Lizenz.
Und die Frage der Kommunikation und Netzwerkfähigkeit.
Genau, also freie Software spielt da eine große Rolle mittlerweile im Embedded-Markt, weil der hohe Bedarf an Anpassung an die jeweilige Hardware setzt einfach die Verfügbarkeit von Source Code voraus. Und an der Stelle fährt eigentlich Linux sehr viel mehr Erfolge ein als auf dem Desktop-Computer.
Wenn man heutzutage über Linux redet in der Öffentlichkeit, dann kommt ja immer die Frage so, ja, kann Linux Microsoft Windows verdrängen?
Ja, keine Ahnung, ob es das irgendwann noch mal kann. Derzeit kannst du es auf jeden Fall nicht.
Bloß andere Märkte sind im Prinzip schon dabei, komplett übernommen zu werden mit Einschränkungen, die du sicherlich gleich erwähnen wirst. Aber ganz klar ist, Linux hat da den Fuß ganz mächtig in der Tür. Gar keine Frage.
Allerdings auch andere offene Betriebssysteme sind dort vertreten, vor allem NetBSD und auch OpenBSD.
OpenBSD bevorzugt so in sicherheitsrelevanten Netzwerkanwendungen, wie zum Beispiel WLAN-Router oder überhaupt generell Router, Firewall-Systeme, kleine Firewall-Systeme, die man mal eben irgendwo dazwischen hängt, als OpenBSD sehr verbreitet.
Wie ist dein Eindruck, Harald?
Ja, ja, selbstverständlich. Also wenn man sich so diesen Netzwerk-Embedded-Markt, also angefangen in DSL-Modem, Router, WLAN-Access-Point, was auch immer, so dieser ganze Dunstkreis, da findet man sehr viel Linux, eben OpenBSD auch, und vor allem VxWorks. VxWorks ist dann eines der kommerziellen Embedded-Betriebssysteme, wenn nicht eigentlich fast das kommerzielle Embedded-Betriebssystem mittlerweile. Ansonsten sieht man eben auch noch QNX, also QNX geschrieben, ebenfalls ein proprietäres, kommerzielles Betriebssystem im Embedded-Bereich.
VxWorks ist das Ding, was ich vorhin erwähnte, mit dem Mars Rover.
Also diese beiden Mars Rover, die fahren unter anderem dieses VxWorks.
Ja, Linux, wie gesagt, ist sehr verbreitet. Das kann man jetzt in unterschiedlichen Begründen, kann man jetzt unterschiedliche Begründungen dafür finden. Zum einen, wie Tim schon angesprochen hat, dass man den Quellcode bekommt, das einfach verändern kann. Das ist natürlich sehr praktisch, weil diese Embedded-Systeme oft sehr spezielle Hardware haben, wo man Anpassungen dran vornehmen muss und das einfach kann, wenn man den Quellcode hat. Ein ganz anderer Aspekt ist aber, und das ist insbesondere im Consumer-Bereich sehr wichtig, die fehlenden Lizenzkosten. Wenn ich einfach irgendwie ein Gerät eine Million mal produziere und das wirklich so ein Massenmarkt ist und ich kann eine Million mal, und wenn es nur 10 Cent sind, sparen, dann habe ich halt schon irgendwie eine Million Euro. Ich habe letztendlich Euro an zusätzlichen Gewinn eingefahren im Vergleich dazu, wenn ich irgendwas Profit-Halos lizenziert hätte, wo ich eben Kosten habe in dem Fall. Und jetzt auch wieder in diesem speziellen Segment der Netzwerk-Embedded-Geräte würde ich mal sagen, zwischen 30 und 40 Prozent Marktanteil Embedded Linux mittlerweile.
Es gibt natürlich auch bestimmte Gerätetypen, da sieht es ein bisschen anders aus, vor allem Mobiltelefone und diese PDAs, wobei PDAs jetzt und diese Smartphones als Embedded-Devices zu bezeichnen. Da kommen wir in diesen schwierigen, schwammigen Bereich, wo es eigentlich gar nicht lohnt, weiter zu diskutieren. Da haben wir auf jeden Fall kleine Geräte, die diese selben Merkmale haben, wie das Embedded-Devices eben haben, sprich wenig Energieverbrauch, kleiner Maßstab von allem, muss klein sein, darf wenig Wärme entwickeln und so weiter und möglichst wenig Kosten. Auf den Telefonen gibt es ja den Kampf zwischen Windows, CE. Auf der einen Seite, Microsoft versucht halt permanent im Telefonmarkt den Fuß in die Tür zu bekommen, es gelingt ihnen nicht zurecht.
Warum nicht?
Gute Frage. Also es gab mehrere Telefone, die angekündigt hatten, mit Windows, CE auf den Markt zu kommen und ganz häufig gab es den Fall, dass sie dann immer kurz bevor sie dann wirklich starteten, das wieder haben sein lassen. Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob die so ein bisschen Angst hatten oder ob die Lizenzbedingungen nicht so richtig toll waren oder ob sie am Ende dann doch von der Marktmacht von Symbian, also was Nokia einsetzt und so ein Ericsson, überrollt wurden. Keine Ahnung, es gibt mittlerweile auch Linux-basierte Telefone. Das spielt noch nicht so die große Rolle, aber ich bin mir sicher, dass sich das relativ bald ändern wird. Es gibt andere Betriebssystem-Entwicklungen wie dieses MAD OS. Du hast das glaube ich schon mal ein bisschen angeschaut.
Ja, da kommen wir dann schon in die Kategorie Hacks hinein. Bislang sprechen wir über Betriebssysteme, wie sie von einem Hersteller oder Anbieter, also auf der einen Seite die Open Source Community, auf der anderen Seite bestimmte Hersteller anbieten und dann eingesetzt werden. Man nehme jetzt VXWorks, das wird lizenziert von einer Firma XYZ, die baut damit ein Gerät. Das MAD OS ist ein GPL lizenziertes Betriebssystem für bestimmte ältere Nokia-Telefone. Das ist eine freie Entwicklung. Das ist ein alternatives Betriebssystem, das ich auf mein Nokia-Telefon aufspielen kann und dann habe ich da ein freies Betriebssystem drauf. Das sind also sehr interessante Entwicklungen, die sich da auch abzeichnen. Das ist dann aber eben ein Embedded System unter einem anderen Betriebssystem oder mit anderer Software laufen lassen, als es der Hersteller ursprünglich ausliefert. Das ist eben eine sehr interessante, spannende Entwicklung, die man in vielen Bereichen sieht, eben eigentlich durch die ganze Bank bei diesen Embedded-Systemen. Man sieht das bei Set-Top-Boxen, bei digitalen Videoempfängern, man sieht das bei Media-Playern, bei diesen Netzwerkgeräten, Routern, iPods, also MP3-Player, dergleichen.
Wobei, mit meinem iPod das hat gestern nicht funktioniert. Also ich hab noch mal versucht, dieses iPod Linux zu installieren. Installieren ließ es sich auch und tatsächlich startete dann auch dieses Podzilla, wie es heißt, aber leider war es nicht in der Lage, meine Musik abzuspielen. Danach war auch das normale, die ein normaler iPod-Software nicht mehr in der Lage, die Musik abzuspielen. Das hat also nicht ganz so gut funktioniert. Macht daran liegen, dass ich einen First-Generation-iPod habe und das mehr auf den späteren Modellen ausgereift ist. Keine Ahnung, eigentlich soll es gehen. Trotzdem, der Trend ist klar. Die Leute stürzen sich auf diese Geräte und schauen, was geht. Und Freilsoftware spielt da eine ganz große Rolle.
Eines der Projekte, das sicherlich als Nummer eins Vorzeigeprojekt für solche Hacks sozusagen dasteht, ist das sogenannte Open-WRT-Projekt. W-R-T bezieht sich hierbei auf den Anfang der Typenbezeichnung eines der populärsten WLAN-Router, nämlich den linkses WRT54G.
Kennen sogar ich.
Da gibt es ein paar baugleiche Modelle von konkurrierenden Herstellern, damit wir hier nicht nur einen nennen. Also von Belkin und von Allnet und von Buffalo gibt es da zumindest baugleiche Geräte, wo man wirklich die Software austauschen kann. Das ist also ein sehr interessantes Projekt, wo eine Community sich gebildet hat, hier eben alternative Software zu bauen. Ähnliches sieht man mittlerweile für Navigationssysteme, wie ich schon sagte, für digitale Satellitendressever und dergleichen. Da werden wir dann in Kürze jetzt auch noch einen, der beteiligt ist an diesen Projekten, ins Telefon mit reinnehmen und dazu interviewen, ein paar Fragen stellen. Aber diese Hacks, es gibt mittlerweile Magazine und Blogs und Webseiten, die sich eigentlich nur mit dieser ganzen Hackerrei der Geräte beschäftigen, also einfach eigene Software installieren. Für viele ist das natürlich ein Selbstzweck, die einfach sagen, ja, das ist einfach cooler, irgendwas drauf laufen zu lassen, was ich kenne oder wo ich selber irgendwie verändern kann. Sehr interessant ist aber eben auch, dass man da schon auch einen Mehrwert mit hineinbringen kann in die entsprechende Software. Also wenn ich ein Navigationssystem im Auto habe und ich kann das dann auch zum Abspielen von MP3s auf einmal verwenden, was mir der Originalhersteller eben nicht erlaubt, dann ist das halt schon irgendwie ein cooler Hack.
Du brauchst aber noch irgendwie eine Quelle für die MP3s.
Ja, das Navigationssystem hat halt irgendwie einen USB-Port.
Da steckst du eine Platte rein oder so ein...
Memories, also so ein Memorystick oder was auch immer.
Aber die meisten Navigationssysteme sind doch sowieso PDA-basiert, die können das doch dann eh, oder nicht?
Ja, das ist wieder was anderes. Aber wir können ja dann noch auf das spezielle...
Es gibt halt solche und solche im Zoo.
Ja, es gibt diese coolen Auspacken, Einschalten geht. Die sind natürlich nicht PDA-basiert.
Ja, oder auch wenn man jetzt in den MP3-Player oder Video-Player-Markt hineinschaut, wenn man dann auf einem Org Walkbus abspielen kann, obwohl der Hersteller das eigentlich mit der Original-Software nicht kann, dann ist das eben auch ein Vorteil.
Zum Beispiel dieses iPod Linux, nicht? Und dann kann man mit deinem iPod auch aufzeichnen. Ja, Mono und Stereo sogar auch.
Line-In und so wird alles unterstützt.
Musst du nur deinen eigenen Stecker löten, den gibt es natürlich nicht seelenmäßig von Apple, aber das Gerät kann das, bloß die Software von Apple erlaubt es nicht. Und das ist natürlich auch schön, wenn man überhaupt erst mal die Hardware vollständig nutzen kann, die man da kauft.
Gestatten die Hersteller das oder schließen die das auch aus?
Na du verlierst die Garantie oder so. Welche Garantie?
Das ist ja das Schöne wiederum, das Schöne an Software, die macht ja in der Regel nicht unbedingt so viel kaputt. Das bedeutet ja nicht unbedingt, ich kann mich natürlich bei dem Stecker jetzt verlöten, aber man findet im Zweifelfall ja auch immer irgendjemanden, der in der Lage ist, einem das besser zu machen.
Also gerade in diesem Einzelzubehörbereich, da gibt es einfach noch fertige Bausätze oder Platine oder Leute, die haben das halt einfach machen.
Keine Ahnung, das ist halt auch noch mal so ein alternativer Markt. Aber diese Geräte sind halt, wie du schon so schön gesagt hast, also dieser Mehrwert, manchmal ist es so ein bisschen so, naja okay, da kann man immer fragen, braucht man das? Also muss ich jetzt auch noch Ox abspielen, weil ich kann ja auch mp3 nehmen, so kann man das natürlich auch sehen. Auf der anderen Seite gibt es auch gerade für diese kleinen Geräte einfach Anwendungen, die sich anbieten. Schöner Begriff ist NAS, Network Attached Storage, da nimmt man halt einfach so ein WLAN-Gerät mit einem USB-Port, steckt da eine USB-Platte dran, die dann vielleicht sogar USB 2.0, also sehr fix angebunden ist. Und wenn man eben dieses Gerät so mitnimmt mit seiner Platte, was weiß ich, geht man zum Freund, will mal so ein bisschen Datei tauschen, gibt ja immer mal wieder so Dateien, die man so tauschen möchte.
Nicht also so Textdokumente, die man selber geschrieben hat und sowas.
Und dann stellt man das Teil einfach mitten in den Raum, steckt es an, dann bootet es und dann kommt es gleich hoch mit natürlich erstmal dem Betriebssystem, macht WLAN, macht gleich ein Netz, wo sich alle einbuchen können, aber dann eben auch gleich die Platte anbieten über SMB oder AFP oder welche Protokolle auch immer oder FTP, sodass man eben das Ding gleich so out of the box ohne irgendeine Verkabelung benutzen kann und das eben überall. Anderes Beispiel ist eine schöne Lösung für dieses Problem, wenn man zu wenig Internet hat. Eine Freundin von mir hat so eine Software geschrieben, auch wieder für diesen Linksys. Das basiert halt alles erstmal auf dem, was sowieso da ist, aber hat das einfach noch erweitert, noch ein Web-Server drauf geworfen, ein bisschen mit PAP-Software da was gehackt. Und wenn man dieses Gerät einschaltet, dann fängt es gleich erstmal an zu gucken, was gibt es denn hier so für Netze? Ah, hier ist ja ein WLAN-Netz und dann versucht es sich da gleich einzuwählen und wenn das nicht klappt, probiert es mal verschiedene Konfigurationen aus und mit dieser IP-Adresse könnt ihr es ja noch mal probieren. Also versucht selbstständig, sich einfach in alles einzuwählen, was um es herumfliegt, solange bis es das irgendwie schafft und dann leuchtet irgendwie was grün auf dem Webbrowser und dann weiß man, jetzt gibt es Internet, ohne dass man irgendwas gemacht hat. Also kann man einfach so ins Kaffee stellen, Steckdose rein, wartet ein paar Minuten und dann hat man Internet.
Das will ich.
Das wollen alle.
Ihr habt Chaosradio 105 auf Fritz, es geht um Embedded Systems, also den Computer in eurer Waschmaschine, damit es auch Leute wie ich verstehen. Es gibt aber noch ganz andere Anwendungen.
Ja, wir haben jetzt am Telefon zugeschaltet den Christian Daniel, der ist Entwickler von Embedded Systemen, hat also eine Firma, die sich auch mit dem Thema beschäftigt und er kennt sich auch mit Open-WRT gut aus und die erste Frage, die ich stellen möchte wäre doch, was für einen Vorteil hab ich denn, wenn ich Open-WRT auf meinem Router laufen lasse, statt dem Originalbetriebssystem?
Ja, erstmal, hallo zusammen.
Hallo, grüß dich.
Ja, Vorteile durch Open-WRT. Also das Originalbetriebssystem, was auf dem Router läuft, ist auch schon Linux und da stellt sich natürlich dann die Frage, was hab ich davon, wenn ich ein anderes Linux draufmache? Ja, der Knackpunkt ist im Endeffekt, dass ja die ganzen vorgefertigten Funktionen verschwinden, also das ist erstmal ein Nachteil vielleicht, die Web-Oberfläche ist weg, aber es kommt was, was so der Hacker wahnsinnig liebt, nämlich eine Befehlszeile.
Das heißt, ich sollte das nicht ausprobieren als einfacher User?
Ja, es gehört schon ein bisschen Wissen dazu, damit dann umzugehen, aber dafür kann man dann mit dem Linksys-Router im Endeffekt alles machen, was ein größerer Rechner eigentlich auch könnte. Also man kann ihn, er hat natürlich seine fünf Netzwerkparts hintendran, man kann ihn dann als Router benutzen und vielleicht Protokolle routen lassen, die er vorher nicht routen konnte. Man kann auch einen Web-Server drauf laufen lassen, der ganz andere Dinge tut als der ursprüngliche. Man kann ihn zum Beispiel auch als Datenlocker benutzen, oder letzten Endes kann man sich da vollkommen austoben an dem Gerät. Man hat im Endeffekt ganz zum Schluss dann einen Rechner, eine CPU, RAM, ROM und kann darauf jedes beliebige Programm laufen lassen, für das man den Source-Code hat und das man dann für die MIPS-CPU, die da drin ist, kompilieren kann. Also im Endeffekt geht es um große Flexibilität. Ihr habt ja vorhin den Hack beschrieben, den Linksys-Router zu benutzen, um im Internet-Café relativ einfach eine Verbindung zu bekommen.
Im Kaffee, nicht im Internet-Café.
Im beliebigen Kaffee.
Ja ok, ich hab das hier auch schonmal so ähnlich probiert. Und dann kommt da noch eine Sache dazu. Und zwar in den neueren Routern, zumindest in den neueren Hardware-Revisionen, gibt es noch zwei serielle Schnittstellen. Die kann man einfach anlöten, das ist sogar super schön auf der Leiterkarte rausgeführt. Naja, von der Garantie sollte man da natürlich nicht mehr so sehr träumen, aber das eröffnet natürlich ganz andere Möglichkeiten noch. Und eine ist zum Beispiel an dem Router dann noch einen GPS-Empfänger anzuschließen und dem im Auto auf die Hutablage zu legen und auch auf der Suche nach WLAN-Netzen dann praktisch gleich noch die Koordinaten mitzulocken. Und wenn man daheim ist, kann man dann die Liste abrufen, wo kann ich überall ein offenes WLAN-Netz finden?
Das War-Driving.
Genau, voll automatisiert und hinten fällt praktisch eine Liste mit Koordinaten heraus.
So, und das packst du jetzt in eine Kiste, machst einen kleinen Drucker dran und verscheuerst das für viel Geld.
Wär mit Sicherheit ein Geschäftskonzept, ja.
Weil der Markt wahrscheinlich doch ziemlich gering ist. Ja, die meisten Leute wollen das doch selber basteln und kein Geld dafür ausgeben. Ja, gut, ein anderes Projekt, das du ja mit dir gegründet hast, ist das OpenTom Projekt. Worum geht es denn dabei?
Also das ist natürlich eine ganz besondere Sache. Da kommen jetzt die Navigationssysteme, von denen ja vorhin schon die Rede war. OpenTom kommt, der Name kommt von TomTom. Das wird vielleicht manchen was sagen. Und da gibt es eben diese Navigationssysteme, die man aus der Packung nimmt, einschalten geht.
Ist das eigentlich wirklich so? Also die werben immer, oder ist das so?
Ja, es ist wirklich so. Man macht den Karton auf, Taste drücken, im Zweifelsfall nochmal ein bisschen den Akku laden und dann kann man losfahren. Das stellt einem noch ein paar Fragen am Anfang, also das haben sie ganz clever gemacht. Das Schöne an den Dingern ist aber, dass es sich im Endeffekt um PDAs handelt, von der Plattform her, von der Hardware, halt ein bisschen anders zusammengebaut, also nicht so schön flach, sondern mehr so, naja, es schaut ein bisschen aus wie ein kleiner Fernseher, das Gehäuse, auch mit einem Touchscreen dran. Und auf diesen Geräten läuft von Haus aus Linux. Also die TomTom Software läuft da unter Linux, ist auch eine erstaunliche Sache, weil die gibt es für Linux nicht zu kaufen, nur eben auf diesen Dingern drauf. Und ja, der Hack-Faktor ist natürlich enorm, weil die Geräte haben zum ersten Mal einen USB-Port hintendran. Der ist normalerweise dazu gedacht, zum Beispiel die Straßenkarte zu aktualisieren, die in dem Ding gespeichert ist. Der Prozessor, der da drin ist, kann aber diesen Port umschalten, sodass er nicht mehr ein USB-Device ist, sondern ein USB-Host. Und dann kann man natürlich auch eine WLAN-Karte anstecken, einen USB-Stick, eine Festplatte. Und da kommen dann natürlich auch die MP3s ins Spiel, die wir vorhin hatten. Es ist relativ einfach, auf dem Ding einen MP3-Player laufen zu lassen, der von einer extern angeschlossenen USB-Platte stundenlang Musik macht. Das war natürlich einer der ersten Hacks, das geht aber noch weiter. Ich habe ja gesagt, es schaut ein bisschen aus wie ein Fernseher. Und es fällt natürlich dann relativ schnell auf, wofür man das noch benutzen könnte.
Warte, ich habe eine Idee.
Fernsehen?
Ja, wäre ein Weg. Hat das Problem, wie kriege ich das Bild da rein? Weil Antennenstecker ist leider keiner dran.
Na, aber ich kann doch... Es gibt doch hier dieses kleine Terratec-Ding, dieses weiße.
Hast du mal Fernsehen geguckt in letzter Zeit?
Das ist unerträglich, Holger.
Was? Unerträglich, Fernsehen. Ich tue das jetzt auch schon eine Weile nicht mehr.
Und es ist befreiend.
Ja, natürlich. Irre. Aber was du meinst, ist natürlich so private Sicherheitskopien der eigenen DVD, richtig?
Ja, das... Man muss hier ein bisschen umkodieren. Also das typische DivX, was man so nach dem Umkodieren hat, hilft einem auf dem Gerät nichts, aber nur wenig, weil es leider sehr groß ist. Und die Bildschirmauflösung natürlich auch nicht groß genug ist auf dem TomTom. Und man könnte das zwar vermutlich runterrechnen, aber die CPU hat nicht ganz die Leistung dafür.
Wie groß ist der Bildschirm? Und was ist da drin genau?
Der hat 320 x 240 Bildpunkte, 16-Bit-Farben, und ist halt wirklich so ein ganz typisches TDA-Display. Also im Endeffekt das Gleiche, was vielleicht auf einem iPack oder einem Saugus oder so was drauf ist, nur halt hochkant eingebaut. Er hat einen großen Lautsprecher eingebaut, nämlich zum Ansagen der jetzt bitte links abbiegen Sprüchle. Und ja, also der macht einen irren Sound eigentlich. Also zum Fernseh gucken ist das klasse. Er hat aber auch unten so eine Sockel-Pin-Leiste, da gibt es so eine Autohalterung dafür, dass man das Ganze am Radio dann noch anschließen kann. Und da gibt es einen Line-Out-Ausgang, links und rechts. Und da kann man dann, wenn man möchte, Kopfhörer anschließen oder was auch immer.
Das Autoradio reicht ja schon.
Ja super, Line-Out ist doch genau das, was ich meinte. Und hat auch mal eine Wettcam angeschlossen, also man kann ja dann auch zusätzlich einen Außenspiegel daraus bauen, der irgendwie nicht fetteriert ist.
Dann haben wir TomTom angeboten. Die sind dann auf uns aufmerksam geworden. Das ist vielleicht auch so ein Nebeneffekt von der Hackerei. Die Firmen sind nämlich durchaus dann auch daran interessiert, von den Ideen was mitzunehmen. Und wir durften dann auch ein Stück weit für die entwickeln. Und bei der Gelegenheit konnten wir natürlich unsere ganzen Spinnereien dort vortragen. Und eine der Ideen war, eine Rückfahrkamera für dieses TomTom zu fabrizieren. Im Wohnmobil oder so ist das mit Sicherheit eine tolle Sache, wenn man hinten keine Sicht hat. Waren es aber nicht so scharf drauf, weiß nicht warum. Vielleicht gibt es das erst in der nächsten Version, wenn wir vergessen haben, dass es unsere Idee war.
Das ist ja auch nicht unbedingt jetzt der Massenmarkt, aber das ist auf jeden Fall ein schicker Hack. Oder mal nach unten oder nach oben, damit man sehen kann, welche Hubschrauber einen gerade verfolgen.
Ob die schwarz sind oder nicht?
Es ist immer noch so, dass dich Hubschrauber verfolgen, Tim.
Dich nicht?
Nein, niemand sonst. Wir sind schon mit meinen im Auto heute gefahren.
Ja, man weiß ja nie.
Ich fahre euch dann zurück. Der Wagen bleibt hier stehen im Sprengwerk.
Ah, guter Dank weiß keiner, wo ich bin. Okay, wir haben dich hier schon wieder unterbrochen, verzeih. Aber was habt ihr denn noch für tolle Ideen?
Das würde mich aber interessieren.
Ideen gibt es eine Menge. Erstmal was die Navigation, also den ursprünglichen Zweck angeht. Man muss das Ding ja nicht komplett zweckentfremfen. Es gibt so Ideen wie zum Beispiel ein Fahrtenbuch anzubauen. Da kann man mit Sicherheit auch Geld mit verdienen, wenn man da eine Zusatzsoftware für schreibt. Man kann natürlich das eingebaute GPS benutzen, um zum Beispiel diese einfachen GPS-Empfänger nachzustellen. Es gibt zum Beispiel von Garmin diese kleinen Dinge, die im Endeffekt nur Koordinaten und Höhe anzeigen und so ein bisschen die Strecke aufzeichnen. Das kann das Taumtum nicht. Das kann dann immer eine Straßenkarte machen. Und man kann dann sagen, ich will Straße so und so, Hausnummer so und so, aber ich kann nicht sagen, ich hätte gern 50er Breitengrad irgendwas. Sowas könnte man anbauen. Ja, ganz großes Projekt ist natürlich der Medienplayer. Da kommt jetzt noch dazu, dass zumindest die kleineren Geräte als Programmsprecher eine SD-Karte benutzen. Und das ist jetzt eigentlich das, was das Ganze sexy macht. Weil man hat natürlich immer Bauchschmerzen dabei, wenn man ein teures Embedded-System nimmt und dann erstmal die Original-Software rausschmeißt. Man weiß ja vorher nicht, ob man die irgendwie da vielleicht nie wieder reinbringt. Und beim Garantieversuch lachen sie einen dann herzlich aus. Und das ist eben hier das Schöne, man kann diese Geräte nicht zerstören. Man zieht einfach die SD-Karte raus, die da dabei war, nimmt eine aus der Digicam vielleicht, macht da seine eigenen Hack-Software-Versuche drauf, schiebt das Ding rein und startet das. Und naja, entweder es läuft oder es crasht, ist egal. Wenn man die Originalkarte wieder reinsteckt, läuft es wieder. Das ist also eine ganz feine Sache, weil es einem wirklich die Angst nimmt.
Die Karte kriegt man da auch leicht raus.
Die ist da direkt vorne dran, ein Schlitz schaut wie so ein kleiner uralter McIntosh aus. Bildschirm unten drunter, Diskettenlaufwerk.
Nur, dass man da die Diskette von Hand rausziehen kann, was man bei McIntosh nicht konnte.
Das ist nicht releasefähig, leider. Es fehlen noch so Sachen wie Vor- und Zurückspulen, ein Menü und Playlist zusammenstellen und dann auf der Karte vielleicht die Filme suchen, die drauf sind. Aber so grundsätzlich ein File abspielen und dazu einen Ton hören, das können wir, ja.
Und wie verhält sich dann die alte Software? Die Software von TomTom läuft dann noch parallel oder nur entweder oder?
Also im Augenblick ist es ein sehr deutliches entweder oder. Das klingt auch damit zusammen, dass die CPU ziemlich extrem am Limit ist. Also da merkt man dann auch, diese Embedded-Systeme sind natürlich niemals zu vergleichen mit einem Pendium, selbst wenn die Megahertz-Zahlen vielleicht recht beeindruckend sind. Also ich kann mich erinnern, so die ersten Rechner, auf denen man flüssig DivX abspielen konnte, das ging so bei Pendium 2 300 Megahertz los. Jetzt so ein größeres Embedded-System, ein großes TomTom, hat einen ARM 9 als CPU, der läuft mit 400 Megahertz und das reicht nicht. Also man muss da auch mal ganz deutlich unterscheiden, diese Megahertz-Zahlen sagen übers Tempo eigentlich gar nichts aus. Große Schuhgröße ist besserer Schuh, das ist totaler Blödsinn. Letzten Endes liegt es daran, dass diese CPUs praktisch keinen CPU-Cache mitbringen, also keinen Level-1 und Level-2-Cache. Und die CPU praktisch die ganze Zeit am Speicherbus nuckelt und versucht, da Bytes rüber zu bringen. Und die RAMs sind ja eigentlich viel langsamer als die CPU und entsprechend bremst sich das recht schnell aus. Und die Pandiums, die da irgendwie mit ihrem halben oder ganzen Megabyte Cache unterwegs sind, können natürlich viel mehr Code da drin halten und den dann viel schneller ausführen, sodass der Megahertz-Faktor da gar nicht so ins Gewicht fällt.
Gibt es eine Webseite zu eurem Hex?
Ja, das ist www.opentom.org. Und da ist ein großes Wiki. Da gibt es eine ganze Menge Sachen, die wir inzwischen veröffentlicht haben. Das ist leider nicht mehr so ganz aktuell. Wir haben inzwischen auch ein Bildsystem gebaut, mit dem man eigene Anwendungen relativ einfach erstellen kann und dann auf dem System zum Laufen bringt. Das ist ja auch immer die Schwierigkeit, wenn ich jetzt so ein Embedded-System habe, also ein Linux-Rechner auf einem PC, das hat ja ein gewisser Anteil der hackenden Bevölkerung schon daheim. Aber einen Compiler für einen ARM-Prozessor oder gerne MIPS-CPU, das hat man dann schon nicht mehr so unbedingt in der Schublade. Und das alles zusammenzubauen, ist vielleicht auch nicht unbedingt das Einfachste. Und wir haben das eben für das TomTom zusammengestellt, die Bibliotheken dazu, die man braucht, und da kann man das im Endeffekt demnächst runterladen, am Block installieren, und dann kann man da loslegen, den C-Compiler anwerfen oder erstmal den Editor aufmachen, reinschreiben, was das Ding dann tun soll, und dann fällt hinten das Pfeil raus, was man später dann auf die SD-Karte kopieren muss.
Vielen Dank, Christian.
Kein Problem.
Danke schön. www.opentom.org Da könnt ihr euch angucken, was man mit dem Navigationssystem noch so alles machen kann.
Wenn Fritz in Fürstenwalde, dann 101, 5.
Fünf nach aber eins.
Fritz Info.
Heute Nacht ist Sternenklar bei 10 bis 16 Grad. Morgen wird es wieder ganz toll. Die Sonne scheint. Die Temperaturen steigen auf 27 bis 30 Grad. Und jetzt die Meldung mit Matthias Karkow.
Nach dem Durchzug des Wirbelsturms Katharina werden im Golf von Mexico 20 Ölplattformen vermisst. Außerdem stehe eine gebrochene Gaspipeline in Flammen, meldete die amerikanische Küstenwache. Es kam zu Preiserhöhungen und langen Autoschlangen vor den Tankstellen. Auch in Deutschland sind die Benzinpreise in bisher nicht gekanntem Ausmaß gestiegen. Präsident Bush will beim Kongress einen Sonderfonds für die Opfer des Hawiken beantragen. Die Lage an der Südküste wird immer dramatischer. Im schon überfluteten New Orleans steigt das Wasser nach mehreren Dammbrüchen immer weiter. Plünderungen sind zur Normalität geworden. Die Stadt soll vollständig evakuiert werden. In der irakischen Hauptstadt Bagdad sind bei einer Massenpanik auf einer Brücke bis zu 1.000 Menschen ums Leben gekommen. Ausgelöst wurde die Panik durch Gerüchte über einen bevorstehenden Selbstmordanstark. Der brandenburgische CDU-Chef Schönbohm will bis 2009 im Amt bleiben. Das kündigte Schönbohm der Tageszeitung Die Welt an. Nach seinen umstrittenen Äußerungen über die Folgen des DDR-Systems war spekuliert worden, dass er bereits 2007 den Parteivorsitz abgibt. Der Verkehr auf Fritz hat keine Meldungen. Wir wünschen gute Fahrt.
Vielen Dank Matthias. Sechs Minuten nach halb eins.
Fritz, eine Produktion des Airbnb.
Samstag nacht Fritzklub Disco.
Die Leute sind super cool, super locker. Keiner guckt drauf, wie man angezogen ist oder wie man rumläuft, was man für eine Frisur hat.
Die Musik ist cool, die Abwechslung. Mal richtig was empanzen.
Jetzt auch mit Chillen und Grillen im Fritzklub-Garten. Immer samstags ab 23 Uhr im Fritzklub im Postbahnhof direkt am Berliner Ostbahnhof.
Mehr Infos fritz.de Und im Radio.
Preis der Musik.
Fritz ist an, Chaosradio 105 läuft, um Embedded Systems geht's und der Reinhard ruft nochmal an und hat eine Frage.
Jo, ich möchte nochmal wissen, ob mir einer der, ob mir die Redaktion von euch oder einer der Hörer nochmal benötig sein kann und zwar suche ich eine Anlaufstelle für ein Embedded System für ein PC auf Intel Basis. Wie gesagt, die Multiple Sclerosis ist mir doch ein bisschen zu viel Software auf einmal.
Ah, na du möchtest also ein Embedded System auf PC Basis haben? Na ja, also was sich da schon anbietet sind die diversen freien Betriebssysteme. Also ob du da jetzt irgendwie NetBSD nimmst oder Linux oder was derartiges, aber das bietet sich eigentlich schon an zum Einsatz auf x86-Plattformen. Ist halt die Frage, was du für Anforderungen hast. Vielleicht kommen wir nochmal in der Sendung auf das Thema Echtzeit zu sprechen. Ja, und zwar genau jetzt. Hast du denn was für Anforderungen hast du denn? Ist das echte, also harte Echtzeit Anforderungen oder was? Was willst du damit tun?
Also Echtzeit wäre schön, wenn es sich bezahlen lässt, in Anführungsstrichen. Ansonsten wäre der Gedanke eigentlich mehr in Multimedia-Server auf PC-Basis, dass du endlich mal dir mal selber so ein PC-Ding zusammenstellen kannst. Weil ein PC gibt es ja sowieso schon.
Ein PC-Ding? Warum willst du denn ein PC-Ding?
Ja, ein Multimedia-Server.
Was soll denn das sein?
Für die Wohnung. Und ich sag mal, ich hab so den Eindruck, also wenn Firmenamen genannt werden, dass dann 2003 Server eigentlich stabil läuft und auch weniger harte Anforderungen oder weniger Software hochlädt beim Starten, als die davorigen.
Also du redest viel über Windows und das geht echt an unserem Thema komplett vorbei, weil Windows hat einfach mit Embedded gar nichts zu tun. Das ist einfach mal was anderes.
Auch unter Windows gibt es Embedded Betriebssysteme. Die kenne ich aber nicht und deshalb ist die Frage.
Das heißt auch Windows. Windows ist das eine Betriebssystem und die anderen sind die anderen Betriebssysteme. Und ein Embedded Betriebssystem muss halt bestimmte Anforderungen haben, die Windows stichend und ergreifend nicht erfüllt, weil sonst würde es ja auf diesem Markt in irgendeiner Form irgendeine Bedeutung haben. Hat es aber nicht.
Meines Wissens nach gibt es Embedded NT 4.0, Embedded XP und irgendwas hier für die Mobilgeräte. Ich kenne aber die Sache nicht im Detail. Und da ist ja nochmal die Frage, ob er vielleicht dazu auch irgendwas sagen könnte. Oder habt ihr einen Hörer, der jetzt dazu irgendwas auf Embedded-Basis gebaut hat?
Tja, ist eine gute Frage. Ich weiß, es gibt halt von Microsoft diese Embedded-Developer-Center-Schnickschmack, Windows Embedded XP. Ich weiß nicht, was ich davon halten soll, um ehrlich zu sein.
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt auch noch kein Gerät gesehen, was das verwenden würde.
Ich auch nicht.
Wir können das gerne mal an die Hörer so weitergeben. Also wer mal ein Embedded-Gerät mit Windows gesehen hat oder da was entwickelt hat, der möge sich mal melden und anrufen. Ja klar.
Und die andere Sache ist, was habt ihr denn in Echtzeit fähig? Was habt ihr denn an Informationen auf dem Tisch?
Was wir da für Informationen auf dem Tisch haben? Da kann ich dir sagen. Na gut, ich meine zunächst einmal Realtime ist eine Fähigkeit eines Betriebssystems, die ja eben in einer garantierten Zeit einen Prozess laufen zu lassen, wenn etwas passiert ist. Das ist erstmal eine grundsätzliche Fähigkeit und das sagt darüber, was du damit tun willst, gar nichts aus. Typischerweise ist es eben gefragt bei der Steuerung, den Regeln von Maschinen, wo es einfach mal ganz wichtig ist, dass irgendein Programm im richtigen Moment Stop sagt, weil sonst die Säge einfach durch irgendetwas durchsägt, wo sie nicht durchsägen soll. Wenn sie an der Grenze angekommen ist und aus diesen Anforderungen heraus definiert sich auch die Anforderungen an die Software. Wenn nicht jedes Betriebssystem hat da eben die gleiche Struktur, obwohl Realtime etwas ist, was heutzutage in zunehmenden Maßen auch in die weiter verbreiteten Systeme sich hineinschleicht. Also auch die letzte Linux-Update hat da gerade in diesem Bereich wieder was Neues hinzugewonnen, aber es gibt schon längere Zeit spezielle Versionen, die von uns schon erwähnten VXWorks, QnX, sind schon immer vom Start weg für den Realtime-Bereich designt worden. Das war quasi das Designziel, eben sehr schnell zu sein, aber nicht nur schnell zu laufen, sondern eben auch schnell ein Programm aktivieren zu können, wenn etwas passiert.
Ja, und vor allen Dingen klein zu sein.
Und natürlich auch klein zu sein, weil es ja primär eben um Embedded-Geräte geht, damit dürfen sie nicht viel RAM belegen und so weiter und so fort. Im Linux-Bereich gab es da auch interessante Entwicklungen. Es gab mal eine Firma, die hat etwas etabliert, es nannte sich RT Linux, da haben sie im Prinzip so einen Miniatur-Nano-Körnel über das Linux drüber gesetzt, was ihm den Zugriff auf die Hardware-Interrupts weggenommen hat und dann lief das Linux als Idle-Prozess quasi noch so hinten mit dran. Das hatte den Vorteil, dass man eben nach wie vor das volle Linux benutzen konnte mit seinen Netzwerk-Fähigkeiten, aber eben auch in der Lage war Software zu schreiben, die volle harte Echtzeitanforderungen erfüllt, wie man das so schön nennt, also wenn es wirklich richtig schön schnell gehen soll. Da gab es allerdings ein bisschen Streit, weil die Jungs sich auch gleich ein Patent darauf angemeldet haben, auf diese Methode, sodass andere Projekte, die einen ähnlichen Ansatz verfolgt haben, da erstmal in ihr Bedürfnis waren. Die hatten da zwar eine Klausel, man durfte das dann eben, wenn man das bei GPL veröffentlicht, dürfte man das Patent auch benutzen, aber das hat auf jeden Fall schon den potenziellen Kundenmarkt da gerade im Industriebereich ausreichend verschreckt. Jetzt haben sie sich da neue Sachen einfallen lassen. Ganz interessant ist da das Projekt ADEOS, was quasi über allen anderen Betriebssystemen läuft und nur diese Hardwareinterrupts verwaltet. Darunter kann man dann eben Linux oder eben noch ein anderes Betriebssystem parallel laufen lassen. Körner, die Barga, das bietet interessante Sachen. Das führt jetzt hier ein bisschen zu weit, da auf diese Details einzugehen, aber wen das interessiert, gerade im Bezug auf die Lizenzproblematik, ist es nochmal ganz interessant nachzuschlagen.
Ja und angerufen auf die Frage, ob irgendjemand mal ein Embedded oder ein Gerät gesehen hat, in dem ein Embedded Windows irgendeine Art drin war, haben wir auch nicht gekriegt.
Also für uns ist das so ein bisschen Vaporware, aber ich will jetzt nicht ausschließen, dass das tatsächlich irgendjemand sich traut, das zu benutzen, aber ich glaube so verrückt sind die wenigsten.
Ja, vielleicht noch mal eine Anmerkung dazu. Microsoft macht sich ja mit den ganzen Updates unbeliebt und deshalb ist auch der Trend auch zum Embedded System oder generell zu anderen Betriebssystemen. So, und die ketzerische Frage wäre, ob, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr Bart-PG kennt, ob da nicht der Ansatz ist, sich ein Embedded oder ein modulares individuelles Betriebssystem auf Windows-Basis zurechtzubiegen? Mal in den Raum reinstellen.
Ich sag dir mal ganz ehrlich, Windows interessiert uns überhaupt nicht. Ich finde, das ist einfach nicht die Zukunft und...
Im Moment muss ich noch, wenn ich konstruiere, muss ich noch auf Windows arbeiten, weil das ist das Betriebssystem für Branche-Software. Ich kann nicht anders.
Genau, aber wir schauen ja hier in die Zukunft und in der Zukunft seh ich das nicht.
Vor allem nicht im Embedded-Bereich.
Schon gar nicht da. Aber eigentlich auch sonst nicht. Also...
Eure noch einen angenehmen Abend dann, ja?
Markus?
Hier ist der Markus, ja.
Ja, du willst uns korrigieren?
Ja, ihr habt grad gesagt, es gäbe kein Embedded-Windows. Also ich hab hier vor mir ein Handy Motorola MPX. 100 oder 200 oder sowas heißt das. Da läuft Windows drauf. Und das hat irgendwie genau dieselben Probleme, wie auch ein Windows PC hat. Super.
Du hast ein Blue Screen auf dem Handy? Du hast ein Blue Screen auf dem Handy?
Nee, dieses Problem nicht. Aber andere schlimme Probleme, zum Beispiel, dieses Handy einzuschalten, dauert ewig. Es braucht ewig zum Hochfahren. Dann kommt eine fürchterliche Windows-Funfahre, die ich auch nicht abschalten kann. Auf dem PC gab es ja wenigstens ein Tweak-UI, da konnte man einfach die überflüssigen Funktionen und blöden Geräusche einfach abschalten. Geht nicht. Und dann, was ich am ärgerlichsten finde, Standbyzeit anderthalb bis zwei Tage. Dann muss ich das Ding wieder aufladen.
Und von meinem Nokia war es...
Wenn es länger Standby hätte, hätte wir irgendwann die Uptime rum.
Meine Vermutung ist einfach, Windows ist so anspruchsvoll für die CPU, dass einfach die Batterie so schnell leer wird. Denn mein vorheriges Nokia-Handy, das hatte ja eine Woche Standbyzeit.
Das ist eine richtig geile Theorie.
Es wäre ein bisschen unfair, das nur auf Windows abzustellen. Es ist halt generell so, dass wenn man sich so die Handy-Generationen anschaut, dann die Telefone, die jetzt mit richtigen Betriebssystemen, also wie jetzt dein Windows-Handy oder eben auch andere Handys, wie Motorola A780 mit Linux oder auch andere Telefone, die große Betriebssysteme fahren, da ist sozusagen ein zusätzlicher Prozessor mit drauf. Ja, weil das eigentliche, also es ist ja nicht so, dass dann die eigentliche Telefonie, also das GSM und so weiter, also die eigentlichen Telefonien, Netzwerffunktionen, dass die dann auf diesem Prozessor laufen, auf dem auch dein Windows oder anderes Betriebssystem läuft, sondern das läuft auf einem zweiten Prozessor daneben. Und dann ist noch mal ein digitaler Signalprozessor drauf. Und dann hast du auch ein größeres Display, üblicherweise bei diesen Smartphones. Das größere Display braucht wieder mehr Strom. Und eben, wie gesagt, du hast einen zusätzlichen dickeren Prozessor. Das ist also schon mal, unabhängig davon, ob das jetzt Windows ist oder nicht, wird die Akkulaufzeit da sicherlich in die Knie gehen. Eineinhalb Tage ist natürlich echt irgendwie ziemlich mystisch. Ja, ist ärgerlich.
Und noch eine ärgerliche Sache, die wir auch von Windows kennen, eine Sanduhr. Also ich will telefonieren und muss auf die Sanduhr warten, ja?
Tja, andere warten auf Sandmännchen.
Also es gibt hier so eine Webseite, wer sich das jetzt mal unbedingt geben will, aber das sagt echt schon eine Menge aus, embeddingwindows.com, und dann noch mal ein bisschen rumklickt. Also ich weiß nicht, da klicke ich ja schon lieber auf rotten.com rum. Die behaupten hier Sachen, das ist irgendwie unglaublich. Also es wäre alles schnell und reliable und secure und es hätte Windows 98 drauf. Also wer es braucht, bitte schön, kauft euch auch gerne Telefone mit Windows CE, wenn ihr damit glücklich werdet. Aber ich glaube, es gibt Alternativen.
Eine Sache, die auch im Irk wieder gefallen ist und die immer wieder kommt, wenn es um Embedded Windows Systeme geht, sind Geldautomaten.
Stimmt.
OS2 war ja eigentlich ganz lange so ganz, ganz vorne.
Schachcomputer war das doch, oder?
Ja, wo war das in Ulm? Genau, die Ulmer hatten mal so einen Geldautomaten aufgetan, wo das, wo irgendwie, was war da noch mal? War da eine Tastatur?
Nee, da war die, da war die, nee, der hatte einen Touchscreen. Und es gab, es gab eine ganze Zeile, eine ganze Zeile war, eine Pixelzeile, die konnte man mit dem Fingernagel irgendwie...
unterziehen und dann hatte man einen OS2-Desktop drauf, genau.
Und dann haben sie dann erstmal den Geldautomaten schachspielen lassen für eine Weile.
Das war ganz lustig.
OS2 war in der Tat lange verbreitet, oder ist, ist all die Räume noch verbreitet bei Geldautomaten. Allerdings ist OS2 als Projekt jetzt offiziell auch von IBM gestorben. Ich weiß nicht so ganz genau, was IBMs Meinung nach die Nachfolge an der Stelle ist. Ich vermute mal, wie ich IBM einschätze, ist das wohl Linux?
Das Problem ist, dass IBM da wenig mit... Also ich kenne da zufällig ein paar Details mit dieser Geldautomaten-Ecke. Und das Problem ist, dass die Hersteller dieser Geldautomaten, also diese Geldautomaten sind im Prinzip echte PCs. Das sind ganz normale Standard-PCs mit eingebaut. Und dann ist halt eine spezielle Hardware, die dann diesen Geldausgabe-Schacht und diesen ganzen Rahmen steuert. Und das Problem ist, dass die Hardware-Hersteller einzig und allein irgendwie Driver für OS2 und eben für Windows NT oder mittlerweile vielleicht XP oder so liefern. Und dass sozusagen die Anbieter von solchen Lösungen, wie IBM, die das ja den Banken verkaufen wollen, gar keine andere Chance haben. Und da gibt es dann die abstruse Konstellation in Brasilien. Ich habe ja mal für Conectiva gearbeitet in Brasilien, dass da tatsächlich dann eine Bank, eine Firma beauftragt, Reengineering der Geldautomaten Hardware zu betreiben, damit sie kein Windows auf den Automaten laufen lassen müssen, sondern eben Linux einsetzen können. Also solche Blüten treibt es dann.
Was dann in den USA wiederum verboten wäre.
Markus, danke für deinen Anruf.
Ja, ich wollte das Handy übrigens auch sofort auf Ebay verticken, als ich es geschenkt bekommen habe vor einem Jahr. Hat mir keiner abgenommen.
Vielleicht ist das off-topic gerade. Du sagst, im Windows ist nicht die Zukunft. Was ist dann die Zukunft?
Die Zukunft sind auf jeden Fall freie und quelloffene Systeme. Also was diesen Embedded-Markt betrifft, noch mal insbesondere. Meine Microsoft kommt doch nicht voran.
Na ja, jetzt haben sie erst versucht, hier das Abgeordnetenhaus zu bestechen in Berlin.
Ja, wo wir dann die Pinguine hingeschickt haben.
Klar, ich persönlich wiederstrebe schon lange der allgemeinen Auffassung, dass man an Microsoft nicht dran vorbei kommt. Sowas kann ich einfach nicht akzeptieren. Und zwar nicht aus Prinzip, sondern einfach weil ich das ganz anders sehe. Selbstverständlich kommt man da dran vorbei. Und nicht nur, indem man es einfach nur ausblendet und ignoriert, sondern viele Leute setzen sich da selber unter einen Gruppenzwang. Und ich sehe das halt eher so wie so eine Modewelle. Nicht die Leute gucken es dir an. Die hören alle die gleiche Musik, sie wählen alle die gleichen doofen Parteien. Und sie müssen überhaupt alle die ganze Zeit immer das tun, was die anderen auch machen und der Nachbar. Und wenn es hip ist, das Handy in so einem ekligen Plastikbeutel am Gürtelbaum zu lassen, dann machen sie das auch alle, bis es nicht mehr hip ist und dann machen sie halt irgendwas anderes, was albern ist. Und immer wenn sie sich auf Fotos sehen, die 10 Jahre alt sind, kommt ihnen selber das kotzen. Und genauso wird das eben mit diesem Windows auch sein. Wir werden irgendwie in ein paar Jahren da sitzen und uns einfach die Bäuche halten darüber, dass wir tatsächlich Windows auf unseren PCs hatten.
Also ich ja nicht, aber viele haben das ja offensichtlich noch.
Aber das ist einfach, ja, das ist nicht die Antwort.
Die Frage und die Antwort ist nein.
Du hältst meinen Bauch, ich halt deinen. Das war Chaosradio 105. Das war's schon, ja.
Das geht aber schnell.
Ja, so rapzap ist die Sendung rum.
Aber wir haben doch noch gar nicht alles.
Ja, schmeißt mal ein paar Minuten.
Da ist ja auch noch so Fahrräder mit so eingebauten Rechnern, habe ich mal gehört.
Stimmt, ja, das war auch ein schönes Embedded-Projekt. Aber davon hast du doch gehört, sicherlich, oder?
Das war in unserer Datenschneider ausführlich beschrieben.
Da gibt es diese Fahrräder der Deutschen Bahn, das Call-a-Bike-System, und die hatten ja... Das ist eigentlich ein sehr pfiffiges System gewesen. Wenn man sich die mal so genauer anschaut, da gibt es da hinten so einen Schließmechanismus, und der blinkt.
Und man ahnt es schon, überall wo was blinkt, da ist unter Umständen eben auch so ein Embedded-System drin. Und so war das auch.
Und dann gab es da so eine findige Gruppe, die sich der Technologie dieses Fahrrades etwas näher angenommen hat und letztlich herausgefunden hat, wie es eben möglich ist, die Software auf diesem Fahrrad zu modifizieren, um ihm sozusagen zusätzliche Funktionalität hinzuzufügen. Großlieber, ist dann eine dicke Sache geworden. Es gibt da ja auch eine ausführliche Dokumentation auf www.ccc.de Call-a-bike slash Call-a-bike, ich weiß jetzt nicht ganz genau. Das zeigt auch, wie die Gesellschaft sich in der Jugend durch solche komplexen Aufgaben nach wie vor anzunehmen. Man muss schon wirklich gut darauf achten, dass man solche Systeme, die in der Öffentlichkeit stehen, wie zum Beispiel diese Fahrräder, auch gut schützt. Man kann hier gar keinen großen Vorwurf machen, weil die tatsächlich ein sehr gutes System gebaut haben. Die ganzen Colobike-Systeme sind wirklich prima. Prima Fahrräder und ich finde auch das Modell ganz gut. Sie haben letzten Endes nur einen einzigen kleinen Fehler gemacht, wo sie ihr System nicht ausreichend zugemacht haben.
Und dann schlüpft dann schon gleich der Ärger in die Geräte hinein.
Was man auch nicht ganz außer Acht lassen kann, ist, wir haben es noch gar nicht erwähnt hier, Harald, dein Projekt, das GPL Violations-Projekt. Viele von diesen Systemen, die halt heutzutage ausgeliefert werden, werden ja schon serienmäßig mit Linux, mit Open Source Software ausgeliefert. Und viele halten sich halt da nicht an die Lizenzbestimmung. Wir haben es auch in Chaos Radio schon erwähnt, aber ich finde es hier noch mal ganz passend. Vielleicht kannst du noch mal deinen eigenen Blick da drauf lenken.
Ja, in der Kürze, es ist ja so, dass freie Software frei kopierbar ist. Also jeder darf die kopieren, jeder darf die einsetzen. Aber bei der sogenannten CopyLeft Software ist es eben so, dass wenn ich Veränderungen an der Software als Hersteller vornehme, dann muss ich diese Veränderungen auch wieder im Quellcode weitergeben, damit eben die Anwender oder interessierten Entwickler sich das anschauen können, verstehen können, das wieder in die Projekte zurück integrieren können usw. Weil der Quellcode eben das ist, womit man arbeiten kann und das einzige Form eines Programms, die der Programmierer verstehen kann. Und es gibt eben Firmen, die hier Linux oder auch andere GPL lizenzierte freie Software einsetzen in ihren Produkten. Die Liste ist da lang und sich leider nicht um die Lizenzbedingungen scheren. Also sozusagen die Veränderungen, die sie vornehmen an der Software, nicht wieder veröffentlichen, entsprechend der Pflichten. Und dann kann man da eben auch was dagegen tun und dem hat sich das sogenannte GPL-Violations.org-Projekt angenommen, was also versucht dann im Zweifelsfall das auch vor Gericht durchzusetzen. Und ich weiß gar nicht, ich glaube so 45-50 Fälle jetzt mittlerweile hinter mir, wo das also erfolgreich geglückt ist.
Das sind doch fast alles solche Embedded-Devices im Wesentlichen, oder?
Ja, zu 98% oder so ist das alles Embedded. Und da gibt es dann doch auch wieder ganz interessante Geräte, wo man feststellt, dass Linux drin läuft. Zum Beispiel, ja, das personal video player, das TomTom, beispielsweise auch ein anderes Navigationssystem. Mittlerweile Navi Flash ist da noch so ein Produkt.
Ganzes WLAN-Router.
WLAN-Router, dann eben auch Satellitenempfänger, also DVB-Receiver in dieser Kategorie. Telefon eben auch, das ist bekannt. Es gibt noch einen interessanten Fall, wo wir vielleicht in zwei Wochen oder so was darüber hören werden. Wo also, wie soll ich sagen, ich kann ja mal sagen, im Gesundheitswesen eines bestimmten Landes in größerem Stile hier lizenzwiesig Linux zum Einsatz kam. Aber gut, das ist eigentlich nicht das Thema, nur so am Rande.
Das gibt es dann demnächst auf den einschlägigen News-Seiten nachzulesen.
Genau, wir warten einfach zwei Wochen ab.
Die sollt ihr natürlich auch weiterhin verfolgen. Wir sind nach wie vor in eurem Feedback interessiert. Wenn euch was zu dieser Sendung noch einfällt, schreibt es bitte auf diese Mitmachseite in der Wikipedia. Link findet ihr alles auf Chaosradio.cc.de. Wir sind auch sehr aufgeschlossen für gute Ideen, was wir denn mit unserem zehnjährigen Geburtstag anstellen sollen, eurer Auffassung nach. Im November sind es dann zehn Jahre Chaosradio. Wir wollten ja eigentlich schon mal die 100 feiern, aber das hat aus verschiedenen Gründen nicht so richtig geklappt. Aber vielleicht finden wir ja noch mal...
Wie wäre es denn, wenn wir uns in der Geburtstags-Sendung einfach betrinken? Also nur wir und alle anderen dürfen mitmachen. Mal gucken, was am Ende bei rumkommt.
erste Vorschlag ist gemacht. Das ist ja eure Meinung. Das ist eine Diskussionsgrundlage jetzt. Nee, aber es ist ganz ernst gemeint, wir sind da für lustige Ideen auf jeden Fall immer aufgeschlossen. Dann gucken wir mal, wer noch für lustige Ideen alles aufgeschlossen ist. Ende des Jahres steht der Kongress an. Wieder in Berlin. Der Call for Papers ist draußen. www.ccc.de einfach mal nachschlagen, da steht alles drauf. Schön weiter reichen. Ein Monat ist noch Zeit, interessante Vorträge einzureichen. Und jetzt fällt mir nichts mehr ein. Dann mach ich Ende. Das war Chaosradio 105 auf Fritz. Es ging um Embedded Systems. Das nächste Chaosradio gibt es am letzten Mittwoch im September. Das ist der 28. September, also in exakt vier Wochen. Vielen Dank Tim, vielen Dank Harald. Und vielen Dank Holger. Und Mahlzeit nicht zu vergessen. Und Mahlzeit. Night Flight mit Martin Petersdorf im Anschluss.